Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. They hit at 7 o'clock in the morning of the 13th of July. Hit hard. Hailstones big as eggs. According to some reports, they were as big as bottles. Chunks of ice, as hard as diamonds, weighing a pound and a half. A hailstone that was weighed in one village outside Paris came to eight pounds.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。7月13日清晨7点，冰雹袭来。来势汹汹。冰雹大如鸡蛋。据一些报道称，它们甚至有瓶子那么大。冰块坚硬如钻，重达一磅半。在巴黎郊外的一个村庄，有人称过一颗冰雹，重达八磅。
One weighed in another village came to ten. The stones broke windows, smashed tiles on roofs, raised fields, destroyed vineyards, stripped bare fruit trees, struck horses dead, and even killed some peasants who were preparing to harvest what had promised to be an excellent crop of wheat. That is Robert Danton in his wonderful book, The Revolutionary Temper, and he is describing the storm that hit France in the summer of 1788. And Dominic, we do love a storm, a gathering storm on The Rest is History. But I mean, you could argue that this is possibly the most significant actual non-metaphorical storm in the
另一个村庄称出的一颗重达十磅。冰雹砸碎了窗户，击碎了屋顶的瓦片，毁坏了田地，摧毁了葡萄园，剥光了果树，砸死了马匹，甚至夺去了一些农民的生命，他们当时正准备收割那本有望获得丰收的小麦。以上内容摘自罗伯特·丹顿（Robert Danton）的精彩著作《革命气质》（The Revolutionary Temper），他描述了1788年夏天席卷法国的那场风暴。多米尼克，我们确实喜欢风暴，喜欢《历史的余味》中那种山雨欲来风满楼的感觉。但我的意思是，你完全可以说这可能是欧洲历史上最重要、最非隐喻意义上的风暴。
whole of European history. You absolutely could, Tom. One would be quite justified in arguing that. So purely in its own terms, it's quite an extraordinary event, a meteorological event. It sweeps all the way across France from Rouen, Normandy, all the way down to Toulouse and the Languedoc. There was a Scottish gardener, a great gardening writer and gardening expert called Thomas Blakey, who was travelling in France in 1788. And he said that the hailstones were so monstrous, so enormous, that the countryside was littered with dead hares and dead partridges. It wiped out budding vines in Alsace,
你绝对可以这么说，汤姆。这样论证是完全合理的。仅就其本身而言，这是一场非同寻常的事件，一场气象事件。它从诺曼底的鲁昂一路横扫法国，直抵图卢兹和朗格多克地区。有一位苏格兰园丁，一位伟大的园艺作家和专家，名叫托马斯·布莱基（Thomas Blakey），他1788年正在法国旅行。他说冰雹大得离谱，大得惊人，以至于乡间到处都是死去的野兔和鹧鸪。它摧毁了阿尔萨斯、
Burgundy in the Loire, Laid waste to wheat ripening in the fields of the Auligny, Pitted young apples in the Calvado. Shriveled young olives and oranges in the Midi. What I like about that is that actually that was Robert Danton. That was a quote from Robert Danton. It wiped out budding vines in Alsace, Burgundy and the Loire. Okay, we don't need it again.
勃艮第和卢瓦尔河谷含苞待放的葡萄藤，蹂躏了奥利尼（Auligny）田野里正在成熟的小麦，在卡尔瓦多斯（Calvado）砸坏了幼小的苹果。我喜欢这段话的原因是，这其实是罗伯特·丹顿写的。这是罗伯特·丹顿的一段引文。它摧毁了阿尔萨斯、勃艮第和卢瓦尔河谷含苞待放的葡萄藤。好吧，我们不需要再重复一遍了。
All right, okay. But anyway, yes, it's a terrible storm. And of course, if you've been listening to this series, which we hope you have, you will know that it strikes at the worst possible moment, when France is gripped by this political and financial crisis. And the storm is then followed by a drought. So a drought across France, then suddenly a very hot summer, and farmers are writing to the court in Versailles sending letters asking for help.
好吧，没问题。但总之，是的，这是一场可怕的风暴。当然，如果你一直在收听这个系列节目（我们希望你听了），你就会知道它发生在最糟糕的时刻，当时法国正陷入政治和金融危机。风暴之后紧接着就是干旱。法国全境遭遇干旱，随后突然迎来了一个酷热的夏天，农民们纷纷写信给凡尔赛宫廷请求援助。
A once ravishing countryside has been reduced to an arid desert. And there's a real sense of kind of catastrophe, which of course in the context of everything that we were talking about in the last episode. Not helpful, is it? It's not helpful at all. The interesting thing actually is that last time we were talking about the Ancien Régime, how the stereotype of it is so misleading. And so it is with this case.
曾经迷人的乡村已沦为干旱的沙漠。这确实给人一种灾难降临的感觉，当然，这与我们在上一集讨论的所有背景有关。这可不是什么好事，对吧？这完全不是好事。有趣的是，上次我们讨论旧制度（Ancien Régime）时，提到关于它的刻板印象是多么具有误导性。这种情况也同样适用于此。
You would think if you had read A Tale of Two Cities and all of the sort of, you know, you used the caricatures of the French Revolution and the French elite, that nobody did anything to help. And you would be wrong, because actually the Archbishop of Paris launches this big charity drive. The king gives a million livres, even though, you know, the monarchy has pretty much run out of money.
如果你读过《双城记》，并且了解那些关于法国大革命和法国精英的讽刺漫画，你可能会认为没有人伸出援手。那你就错了，因为实际上巴黎大主教发起了一场大规模的慈善募捐。国王捐出了一百万里弗尔，尽管你知道，君主制政府的钱已经几乎花光了。
A national lottery is organized and it raises 12 million livres to pay for relief. But as we will see, it is not remotely enough to rescue the situation because, Tom, nature has more storms in store. Wow. So the elements are combining against the monarchy. They are indeed. And the Ancien Régime. Is in a mess.
政府组织了一场国家彩票，筹集了1200万里弗尔用于救济。但正如我们将要看到的，这远不足以挽救局势，因为汤姆，大自然还准备了更多的风暴。哇。所以大自然的力量正在联合起来对抗君主制。确实如此。而旧制度正陷入混乱。
I think it's fair to say. Were you trying to think of a meteorological metaphor? No, I've moved on from the meteorological metaphors. I was maybe thinking of a building one. I was thinking perhaps it's tottering on its foundations. It is tottering on its foundations. Because as we discussed at the end of the last episode, something looking very much like a French revolution has already broken out in
我觉得这样说很公允。你刚才是在想一个气象隐喻吗？不，我已经不再使用气象隐喻了。我可能是在想一个建筑方面的隐喻。我在想，也许它正摇摇欲坠。它确实在摇摇欲坠。因为正如我们在上一集结尾所讨论的，一场看起来非常像法国大革命的运动已经爆发了，
Grenoble and in Dauphine in the southeast of France and has spread to other provinces. Louis XVI, in desperation, has announced that he will call the Estates General. And we ended last time with the bombshell that Archbishop Brienne, the finance minister, has basically declared bankruptcy, at his partial bankruptcy. And it's ironic, isn't it? Because he doesn't believe in God, but all these acts of God have now hit France. Yes, ironically. Well, he didn't believe in the deficit, and then he was appointed to look at the books.
在法国东南部的格勒诺布尔和多菲内，并蔓延到了其他省份。路易十六在绝望中宣布将召开三级会议。我们上次结束时抛出了一个重磅炸弹：财政大臣布里安大主教基本上宣布了破产，或者说是部分破产。这很讽刺，不是吗？因为他不相信上帝，但所有这些“上帝的旨意”现在都降临到了法国头上。是的，很讽刺。好吧，他不相信赤字，然后他就被任命去查账了。
He's on a learning curve. Yeah, he is. Well, his learning curve is abruptly terminated a week later, the 25th of August when he is booted out and the monarchy turned to the one person who everybody in France thinks can rescue the situation. This is a man we mentioned very briefly last time. His name is Jean-Jacques Necker and he is not a courtier. He is not an aristocrat. He is not even French he is a Swiss Protestant from a Geneva banking family and he is meant to be the great financial whiz kid of Western Europe because the Swiss even then have a kind of reputation for sobriety and the kind of man that you would trust to sort out your bank balance totally they do Necker is a it seems odd now from our perspective all these centuries later, to comprehend how a Swiss banker could be such a folk hero across France.
他正在经历一个学习曲线。是的，确实。好吧，他的学习曲线在一周后的8月25日戛然而止，当时他被踢出局，君主制转向了法国每个人都认为能挽救局势的那个人。这就是我们上次简要提到的那个人。他的名字叫让-雅克·内克（Jean-Jacques Necker），他不是朝臣。他不是贵族。他甚至不是法国人，他是一位来自日内瓦银行家族的瑞士新教徒。他被认为是西欧伟大的金融天才，因为即使在当时，瑞士人也有一种清醒的声誉，是那种你可以信任去理清银行账目的人。确实如此。内克是一个……从我们几个世纪后的视角来看，很难理解一个瑞士银行家怎么会成为整个法国的平民英雄。
Yeah, I know. But absolutely, there was a sense in France in the late 18th century that Protestants, although they are weird, alien and heretical, are nevertheless very boring and they can be trusted. They're kind of black sober suits and all that kind of thing. So when I was reading up on NICR, I was reminded of how a lot of people in Britain thought about the Canadian national banker, Mark Carney. A listener to The Rest Is History. A listener to The Rest Is History, exactly, who ran the Bank of England.
是的，我知道。但绝对是这样，18世纪末的法国有一种感觉，即新教徒虽然古怪、外来且异端，但他们非常无聊，而且值得信赖。他们总是穿着那种黑色清醒的西装之类的。所以当我查阅关于内克的资料时，我想起了英国很多人对加拿大国家银行家马克·卡尼（Mark Carney）的看法。《历史的余味》的听众。正是《历史的余味》的听众，他曾执掌英格兰银行。
And there was a perception, I think, in Britain that he was very measured, very Canadian, very kind of controlled and kind of apparently very sober. I mean, I'm not saying he wasn't sober, but... What are you saying, Dominic? The avoidance of doubt. That's how he appeared. If he's listening, Dominic is not accusing you of being a drunk. No, I'm not.
我认为英国当时有一种看法，认为他非常审慎、非常加拿大、非常克制，而且看起来非常清醒。我的意思是，我不是说他不清醒，但是……多米尼克，你想说什么？为了避免歧义。他就是那样表现的。如果他在听的话，多米尼克并没有指责你是个酒鬼。不，我没有。
But I'm saying people attributed him, people who knew nothing about Mark Carney, precisely because he was an outsider, not tainted by British politics. People attributed him with sort of extraordinary powers, and they saw him as a figure who represented stability and solidity. And also neutrality. Yeah, neutrality, exactly. And objectivity, not having too many vested interests. And I guess that's why people think Necker is a deus ex machina.
但我想说的是，人们赋予了他某种特质，那些对马克·卡尼一无所知的人，仅仅因为他是个局外人，没有受到英国政治的玷污。人们赋予了他某种非凡的力量，并将他视为代表稳定和坚实的人物。还有中立性。是的，中立，没错。还有客观性，没有太多的既得利益。我想这就是为什么人们认为内克是“机械降神”（deus ex machina）。
They do, indeed. Someone who can be introduced to kind of cut through all the Gordian knots that have been strangling the French economy. We love it. I mean, not just one Gordian knot, according to you, but multiple Gordian knots. All of them. And Necker, to be fair, is brilliant at,
他们确实这么认为。一个可以被引入来切断所有束缚法国经济的“戈耳狄俄斯之结”的人。我们喜欢这个。我的意思是，不仅仅是一个戈耳狄俄斯之结，按照你的说法，而是多个戈耳狄俄斯之结。所有的结。而且平心而论，内克非常擅长，
I mean, the one thing he had done is he'd got loans for the American war, you might argue, with disastrous consequences. He's very good at getting loans because he has so many friends in the banking business. So as soon as he arrives, he says, I can do what Brienne could not. I can get my friends to lend you money at decent rates. I will be able to tide us over for at least another year until the Estates General can meet and we can actually sort this thing out and perhaps set up some new constitutional body or whatever it might be that will approve
我的意思是，他做过的一件事就是为美国战争争取到了贷款，你可能会说，后果是灾难性的。他非常擅长争取贷款，因为他在银行业有很多朋友。所以他一到任就说，我能做到布里安做不到的事。我可以让我的朋友以合理的利率借钱给你。我至少能让我们撑过下一年，直到三级会议召开，我们能真正解决这个问题，或许建立某种新的宪法机构或其他什么东西来批准
taxes. And so the stock exchange, which had been very jittery in the summer of 1788, kind of returns to normal. And there's a sense, you know, maybe we've got a bit of direction, maybe we've got a bit of calm. But I think that sense, Tom, would be illusory. Well, because surely people know that there's an absolute catastrophe looming because the hailstones have wiped out the wheat harvest. They do indeed.
税收。于是，1788年夏天一直非常紧张的证券交易所恢复了正常。人们有一种感觉，你知道，也许我们有了一点方向，也许我们有了一点平静。但我认为那种感觉，汤姆，是虚幻的。好吧，因为人们肯定知道一场绝对的灾难即将来临，因为冰雹摧毁了小麦收成。他们确实知道。
And that, of course, has terrible implications for bread it does indeed there is a sense i think that all the time something is simmering so when brienne fell there were celebrations in paris that turned into rioting um there was fighting between the paris watch and these celebrators stroke rioters perhaps 20 people were killed in the fighting. I mean, this is fighting with your classic kind of the watch have sabres and bayonets. By the end, they're firing into the crowds. Soldiers restore order in the capital eventually. But exactly as you say, because of the storms, everybody knows that something very bad is going to happen. And the reason is this thing about bread. It's the classic thing in the french revolution is that you get great hordes of people chanting for bread that's one of the one of the kind of images yeah and the reason for this is that three out of four people
这当然对面包产生了可怕的影响。确实如此，我认为一直有一种感觉，某种东西正在酝酿之中。所以当布里安倒台时，巴黎的庆祝活动演变成了骚乱。巴黎卫队和这些庆祝者兼暴徒之间发生了冲突，大约有20人在战斗中丧生。我的意思是，这是那种经典的战斗，卫队有军刀和刺刀。最后，他们向人群开火。士兵们最终恢复了首都的秩序。但正如你所说，因为风暴，每个人都知道会发生非常糟糕的事情。原因就是关于面包的这件事。这是法国大革命中的经典场景，你会看到大批人群高喊着要面包，这是那种标志性的画面之一。是的，原因在于法国四分之三的人口
in france subsist almost entirely on a basically a particular kind of loaf which is called the four pound loaf and you need for if you've got a family of four you need two of these loaves every day to feed them. Now, one loaf costs eight sous, and a manual labourer makes about 25 sous a day. So in other words, he will be spending half, maybe more than half of his daily income on these two loaves of bread. And if the bread prices rise, he's in a real mess. So by October, the price has already gone from 8 to 12 Su, and eventually, as we will see, it will peak at about 15 Su. And it peaks, doesn't it, on the 14th of July, 1789? Yeah, 14th of July, 1789, day of the fall of the Bastille.
几乎完全靠一种基本的面包生存，这种面包被称为“四磅面包”。如果你有一个四口之家，你每天需要两个这样的面包才能养活他们。现在，一个面包要八苏（sous），而一个体力劳动者每天大约赚25苏。换句话说，他每天收入的一半，甚至可能超过一半，都要花在这两个面包上。如果面包价格上涨，他就真的陷入困境了。所以到了十月，价格已经从8苏涨到了12苏，最终，正如我们将要看到的，它将达到约15苏的峰值。而且它在1789年7月14日达到顶峰，对吧？是的，1789年7月14日，巴士底狱陷落之日。
Now you could say, I mean, there's nothing anyone can do about this. This is a complete act of God. You know, the storms have destroyed the harvest. There are not enough crops, not enough wheat. There's not going to be enough flour. There's not going to be enough bread. Prices will rise. But this is an age of pamphlets and of rumours and therefore of conspiracy theories, right?
现在你可以说，我的意思是，对此谁也无能为力。这完全是上帝的旨意。你知道，风暴摧毁了收成。没有足够的农作物，没有足够的小麦。没有足够的面粉。没有足够的面包。价格会上涨。但这是一个小册子和谣言的时代，因此也是阴谋论的时代，对吧？
And so if something bad happens, someone must be to blame. Exactly. That's exactly it. Ever since the whole issue was opened by Calonne, and obviously many ways going back even further, there has been this rhetoric of the king's ministers, the king's ministers who are despotic and they don't care and they just want to trample on our ancient liberties and all of that stuff. And now people start to say, well, this is all the fault of the king's ministers. They're not giving us any relief. They're probably hoarding grain
所以如果发生了坏事，一定有人要负责。没错。就是这样。自从卡隆（Calonne）开启了整个问题，显然在很多方面甚至可以追溯到更早，就一直存在着一种关于国王大臣的修辞，说国王的大臣们是专制的，他们不在乎，他们只想践踏我们古老的自由等等。现在人们开始说，好吧，这都是国王大臣的错。他们没有给我们任何救济。他们可能自己囤积了粮食，
themselves, to be honest. They're probably profiting from all this and driving prices up. Only the Estates General can save us. And then if that's not bad enough, I promised you that nature had more tricks up her sleeve, Tom. On the 26th of November 1788, there is an unexpected snowfall. Basically, winter has come unexpectedly heavily and unexpectedly early. And this kicks off what Robert D'Arnaud describes as the longest, cruelest, coldest winter that anybody in France had ever known. So by December, Paris is completely covered with snow. The Seine is frozen over. People are walking on the Seine.
说实话。他们可能从中获利并推高了价格。只有三级会议能拯救我们。如果这还不够糟糕，我向你保证，大自然还有更多的诡计，汤姆。1788年11月26日，一场意想不到的降雪发生了。基本上，冬天出人意料地猛烈且提前到来。这开启了罗伯特·达诺（Robert D'Arnaud）所描述的法国人所经历过的最漫长、最残酷、最寒冷的冬天。所以到了十二月，巴黎完全被积雪覆盖。塞纳河结冰了。人们在塞纳河上行走。
There are frozen bodies lying in the streets. By New Year's Eve, the temperature has fallen to the lowest ever recorded in France, minus 10 degrees Fahrenheit. The rivers are all frozen. Of course, the rivers being frozen means that the water mills, they can't create flour. The rivers are frozen. The roads are snowbound. They cannot transport supplies of bread to those areas that are suffering the most. And the snow is everywhere in France. It's as far south as the Languedoc in the southwest. And it falls pretty much every other day between February and April 1789. I mean, this is a real freak winter.
街上躺着冻僵的尸体。到了除夕夜，气温降至法国有记录以来的最低点，华氏零下10度。河流全部结冰。当然，河流结冰意味着水磨坊无法生产面粉。河流结冰了，道路被大雪封锁。他们无法将面包供应运送到受灾最严重的地区。雪覆盖了法国各地。一直到西南部的朗格多克。而且在1789年2月到4月之间，几乎每隔一天就下一次雪。我的意思是，这是一个真正的反常冬天。
And so they must all be sitting in Versailles looking out of the window thinking, oh no. Completely they are, yeah. Because they're getting reports all the time that basically there's a lot of people in France who are kind of labourers with no land and they rely on seasonal work and they're all out of work and they're just starving you know they have no money they have no food and dying presumably and dying yeah the majority of french men and women are peasant sharecroppers smallholders
所以他们一定都坐在凡尔赛宫，看着窗外想，噢不。完全是这样，是的。因为他们一直在收到报告，基本上法国有很多人是那种没有土地的劳动者，他们依赖季节性工作，现在他们都失业了，他们正在挨饿，你知道，他们没有钱，没有食物，大概正在死去。是的，正在死去。大多数法国男女都是佃农、小农，
so they work their land they owe the senior the local landowner they owe him for goods and stuff and they they owe him various exactions with this winter following on the storm they probably won't be able to pay him what they owe this means that they will probably be evicted from their land and they will be demoted to the class of those people who have no land but at least they have the consolation of knowing that the senior doesn't have to pay taxes, so that must be a rule. Yeah, that the seigneur is fighting for the liberties of France. Yeah, for the liberty of his right not to pay taxes.
所以他们耕种土地，他们欠领主（seigneur）——当地的地主——货物之类的东西，他们欠他各种苛捐杂税。随着这个冬天紧随风暴而来，他们可能无法支付所欠的债务。这意味着他们很可能会被赶出土地，降级为那些没有土地的人。但至少他们有一个安慰，那就是知道领主不需要纳税，所以这一定是一条规则。是的，领主正在为法国的自由而战。是的，为了他不用纳税的权利的自由。
Tom, I think it's fair to say that in general and the rest is history, we deplore people who don't pay their rightful taxes. Don't we? I think we do. We set out our position a year ago in the series on the American War of Independence.
汤姆，我认为可以公平地说，在《历史的余味》中，我们通常谴责那些不缴纳应缴税款的人。不是吗？我想我们是。我们在一年前关于美国独立战争的系列节目中阐明了我们的立场。
We did. And we're sticking to it now. Just pay your taxes, for God's sake. French, American, what is wrong with you people? But this is such a hostage to fortune when we get investigated by tax authorities. That's true. So now, anyway, you have a flood of people moving into the cities, desperate for relief. But if they manage to get there through the snow, there is very little there for them
我们确实这么做了。我们现在仍然坚持这一点。看在上帝的份上，把税交了。法国人、美国人，你们这些人怎么了？但当我们被税务机关调查时，这真是个软肋。那是真的。所以现在，无论如何，你有一大群人涌入城市，渴望救济。但如果他们设法穿过大雪到达那里，那里几乎没有什么东西给他们，
because France already is suffering from quite high unemployment in the cities because, as we said right at the beginning of the last episode, the Ancien Régime is a modernising regime. We're living in the age of the Industrial Revolution. People are being, weavers, artisans, are being put out of work by machines,
因为法国已经在城市中遭受了相当高的失业率，因为正如我们在上一集开头所说的那样，旧制度是一个现代化的政权。我们生活在工业革命时代。人们，织布工、工匠，正被机器、
by capitalism. And by Britain. And by Britain. More specifically. Yeah, because Calon, who we wanted to liberalize the French economy, had signed, this is very Brexit negotiations, he'd signed a free trade deal with the British. And he'd said, this will give us the shock we need, a bit of competition, a bit of, you know, a spur to our economy. A flood of British manufactured goods. Cheap gloves and things. Cheap gloves that are putting the French out of work.
被资本主义所取代。还有被英国。还有被英国。更具体地说。是的，因为卡隆，我们想要自由化法国经济的那个人，签署了——这非常像英国脱欧谈判——他与英国人签署了一项自由贸易协定。他说，这将给我们带来我们需要的冲击，一点竞争，一点，你知道，对我们经济的刺激。大量英国制造的商品。廉价的手套之类的。廉价的手套让法国人失业了。
That's what my ancestors made in Derbyshire. They were making gloves. Really? Yeah. So basically your ancestors are responsible for the Day of the Tiles in Grenoble. We played our bit. Wow. Tom, you kept that quiet during that whole incident when 12-year-olds were being shot.
那是我祖先在德比郡制造的东西。他们当时在做手套。真的吗？是的。所以基本上你的祖先要为格勒诺布尔的“瓦片日”（Day of the Tiles）负责。我们尽了自己的一份力。哇。汤姆，在整个事件中，当12岁的孩子被枪杀时，你一直保持沉默。
But now you bring it up. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I've actually forgotten about it. Oh, right. That's the word. That's even worse. It's the indifference.
但现在你提出来了。噢，是的。是的。我其实已经忘了。噢，对。就是那个词。那更糟糕。那是冷漠。
It's the indifference to the suffering you've caused. Right. So over the winter of 1788, about a fifth of the population of Paris are unemployed. So that's what, about 100,000? 100,000 people, yeah. Well, or receiving relief of some guy, like poor relief. So now we have the three ingredients that we talked about last time. The political and financial crisis, the kind of high politics.
那是对你造成的痛苦的冷漠。好吧。所以1788年冬天，巴黎大约五分之一的人口失业。所以那是多少，大约10万？10万人，是的。或者接受某种救济，比如贫困救济。所以现在我们有了上次讨论的三个要素。政治和金融危机，那种高层政治。
The cultural moment, the cult of virtue, of passion, of living your truth, all of that stuff. And now the social unrest and the anger and the desperation. So this is a lot of pressure on the Estates General, which has been called and is supposed to resolve all this. And the thing is, they've called the Estates General, and it's going to meet the following spring, summer. The date is a slightly movable feast.
文化时刻，美德崇拜、激情、活出真我，所有这些东西。现在还有社会动荡、愤怒和绝望。所以这对三级会议施加了很大的压力，会议已经被召集，本应解决所有这些问题。问题是，他们召集了三级会议，它将在接下来的春天、夏天召开。日期是一个稍微可以变动的节日。
But they don't really know, as we said, what it is, how it will be arranged. There's no institutional memory of it because it hasn't met since 1614-15. And the king has not decreed what it should be? No. There's a flood of pamphlets. There's a huge sort of torrent of argument in the final months of 1788. And what people want, if they are kind of reformers, they say, the third estate, which is the commonsons representing the great majority of the french people should absolutely not allow itself to be outvoted by
但正如我们所说，他们并不真正知道它是什么，它将如何安排。没有关于它的制度记忆，因为它自1614-15年以来就没有召开过。国王没有颁布它应该是什么样子吗？没有。到处都是小册子。在1788年的最后几个月里，有巨大的争论浪潮。人们想要的是，如果他们是某种改革者，他们会说，第三等级，即代表法国绝大多数人民的平民，绝对不应该允许自己被
the clergy and the nobility so the clergy the first state nobles of the second state exactly the mass everybody else is the third estate everybody else yeah the third estate should have its numbers doubled so it should be equivalent to those two. And they should all sit together so that a majority vote can decide all the big questions. Because even if its numbers are doubled, if it's outvoted by the other two chambers, if each chamber gets basically one vote, as it were, then they'll never be able to win. And can I ask, with all this talk about the general will of the people, which is already becoming very current, is there already a sense that actually there shouldn't be three estates, there should just be the one national assembly, which could speak and articulate the truth of the nation? Yes. And this is the moment when people
教士和贵族投票否决。所以教士是第一等级，贵族是第二等级。没错，大众，其他人都是第三等级。其他人，是的。第三等级的人数应该加倍，这样它就应该等同于那两个等级。而且他们应该坐在一起，这样多数票就可以决定所有重大问题。因为即使它的人数加倍，如果它被其他两个议院投票否决——如果每个议院基本上只有一票的话——那么他们就永远无法获胜。我可以问一下吗，随着所有关于人民公意的讨论——这已经变得非常普遍——是否已经有一种感觉，即实际上不应该有三个等级，而应该只有一个国民议会，它可以表达和阐明国家的真相？是的。这就是人们
start to say that. So people had not really been saying that so openly in 1780 or something. But now by 1788, they're saying it very openly. And the most famous example of that, actually, Tom, is a guy called Siez, the Abbe Siez, Emmanuel Siez. So he is from a commoner family and he had become a kind of church administrator and shark. And he writes a very famous pamphlet. If anyone has ever done this for A-Level like me, they will remember this. He wrote a pamphlet called Qu'est-ce que le tiers état? What is the third estate? Which came out in January 1789. And it started with these famous words. We have three questions to ask. First, what is the third estate? Everything. Second, what has it been in the political order up to now?
开始那样说的时候。所以人们在1780年左右并没有那么公开地那样说。但到了1788年，他们非常公开地说了。最著名的例子其实是，汤姆，一个叫西哀士（Siez）的人，西哀士神父，埃马纽埃尔·西哀士（Emmanuel Siez）。他来自一个平民家庭，成为了一名教会行政人员和鲨鱼。他写了一本非常著名的小册子。如果有人像我一样做过A-Level考试，他们会记得这个。他写了一本名为《什么是第三等级？》（Qu'est-ce que le tiers état?）的小册子，于1789年1月出版。它以这些著名的话开头。我们有三个问题要问。第一，什么是第三等级？一切。第二，它在目前的政治秩序中是什么？
Nothing. Third, what does it demand? To become something. So this sort of idea that the third estate is everything. And he says, he says, the third estate is a complete nation. He says there are 25 million of us. There are only 200,000 of them, nobles and priests. We don't even need them. He says, we are the nation. If we want a total reboot of France, we can have one. If we lack a constitution, we must make one, the nation alone has that right. I mean, he presumably, I mean, he's a member of the first estate. Yes. And we talked in the previous episode that there are nobles, members of the second estate
什么也不是。第三，它要求什么？成为某种东西。所以这种认为第三等级是一切的想法。他说，第三等级是一个完整的国家。他说我们有2500万人。他们只有20万人，贵族和教士。我们甚至不需要他们。他说，我们就是国家。如果我们想要对法国进行全面重启，我们可以进行一次。如果我们缺乏宪法，我们必须制定一部，只有国家才有这个权利。我的意思是，他大概——我的意思是，他是第一等级的成员。是的。我们在上一集讨论过，有贵族，第二等级的成员
who sympathize with this. Yes. That, you know, they would like to see their order, their estate dissolved into the entirety of a single assembly. They absolutely would. Yeah, they would. So we'll see a very famous example in the Comte de Mirabeau, who is one of the most famous spokesmen for the third estate, but is a nobleman. And of course, also the Duke of Orléans, who again we talked to, the cousin of Louis XVI, who is a real hint of menace in that pamphlet, What is the Third Estate? He says, if the nobility and the clergy, like me, want to become part of the nation,
同情这一点。是的。他们希望看到他们的等级、他们的阶层融入单一议会的整体中。他们绝对希望。是的，他们希望。所以我们将看到一个非常著名的例子，米拉波伯爵（Comte de Mirabeau），他是第三等级最著名的发言人之一，但他是一位贵族。当然，还有奥尔良公爵（Duke of Orléans），我们之前也谈到过，路易十六的表亲，他在那本小册子《什么是第三等级？》中有一种真正的威胁暗示。他说，如果贵族和教士像我一样想成为国家的一部分，
they must discard their privileges. And he says, people are always asking what place should they occupy in the social order. He says, this is equivalent to asking what place should be assigned to a malignant disease which preys upon and tortures the body of a sick man. I mean, that analogy, your opponents are not even traitors, they are a disease. Yeah, it's very familiar, isn't it? I mean, that is very familiar and very disturbing. So anyway, in this argument, Necker suggests a compromise and he and the king issue a decision. The third estate will get its key demand. It will get 600 deputies compared with the 300 or so for both the clergy and the nobility. Also, the third estate will be able to elect, choose as representatives, people like Siez who come from the other estates.
他们必须抛弃他们的特权。他说，人们总是问他们在社会秩序中应该占据什么位置。他说，这相当于问应该给一个折磨病人的恶性疾病分配什么位置。我的意思是，那个类比，你的对手甚至不是叛徒，他们是一种疾病。是的，这很熟悉，不是吗？我的意思是，这非常熟悉且非常令人不安。所以无论如何，在这个争论中，内克建议妥协，他和国王发布了一项决定。第三等级将得到它的关键要求。它将获得600名代表，而教士和贵族各有300名左右。此外，第三等级将能够选举、选择像西哀士这样来自其他等级的人作为代表。
So if you're, Tom, a liberal reforming clergyman like him or a vicomte or whatever, and your own estate won't choose you, obviously, you could run in the third estate elections to get in that way. However, what does not decide is whether the three estates are all going to sit together, which would allow the third estate to dominate, or whether they would still be stratified kind of hierarchically and be in their different chambers. So this kicks off these elections for the three estates. And they're very, very complicated. So let's try to steer clear of them as much as possible. Basically, it's a filtration process.
所以如果你，汤姆，是一个像他那样的自由改革派教士，或者是一个子爵什么的，而你自己的等级不会选择你，显然，你可以在第三等级的选举中参选以进入。然而，没有决定的是这三个等级是否会坐在一起，这将允许第三等级占据主导地位，还是他们仍然会分层，处于不同的议院中。所以这开启了这三个等级的选举。它们非常、非常复杂。所以让我们尽量避开它们。基本上，这是一个过滤过程。
You've got a parish assembly and then a district assembly and then a provincial assembly. It kind of varies from place to place, doesn't it? It does. It's all kind of random. Yeah, very complicated. And all the time, people have been encouraged. And this is an amazing thing. The king says to them, I want to hear all your grievances.
你有一个教区议会，然后是一个地区议会，然后是一个省议会。它因地而异，不是吗？确实。这都是随机的。是的，非常复杂。而且一直以来，人们都受到鼓励。这是一件了不起的事情。国王对他们说，我想听到你们所有的不满。
I want to hear all your desires. So actually, the idea that the elite and the regime is totally indifferent and out of touch is not quite right. But this is the king. This is him playing his role of the father, the father of the nation. Yeah, the patriot king. Because of course, I assume at this point, the implications of all this identification of the third estate with the voice of the people, they're not yet discussing what implications that might have for the monarch.
我想听到你们所有的愿望。所以实际上，认为精英和政权完全冷漠且脱离现实的想法并不完全正确。但这是国王。这是他在扮演父亲的角色，国家的父亲。是的，爱国国王。因为当然，我假设在这一点上，所有这些将第三等级与人民的声音联系起来的含义，他们还没有讨论这可能对君主产生什么影响。
No, because they're all, by the way, they're all monarchists. Of course. I mean, there is very little, certainly in the books that I've read, there's no mention of any overt republicanism at this stage. Their dream, remember, a lot of these reformers is a British style system, not an American republic. So the ordinary people are composing these 25,000 dossiers, they could call them exercise books, you could call them, in which they basically are saying, well, I don't like this tax. I don't like the senior does this. I would love to live with this or that or whatever this is. But no one in Europe has ever, I think possibly in the world, has ever done an exercise
没有，因为他们所有人，顺便说一句，他们都是君主主义者。当然。我的意思是，几乎没有——当然在我读过的书中——在这个阶段没有提到任何公开的共和主义。他们的梦想，记住，这些改革者中的许多人，是一个英式制度，而不是一个美国共和国。所以普通民众正在撰写这25,000份档案，你可以称之为练习册，在其中他们基本上是在说，好吧，我不喜欢这个税。我不喜欢领主这样做。我希望能过上这样或那样的生活，或者无论这是什么。但我想可能世界上没有人做过这样的练习
like this before. It is a monumental sort of public opinion survey. And does it help stabilize the situation? Well, obviously the problem with it is that because it's unprecedented and extraordinary, it raises expectations. No government, even a revolutionary government, can possibly meet because people then, as now, they want impossible and contradictory things. They want more food. They want more freedom. They want lower prices.
以前。这是一个纪念碑式的公众舆论调查。它有助于稳定局势吗？好吧，显然它的问题在于，因为它前所未有且非同寻常，它提高了期望。没有政府，即使是革命政府，也可能满足这些期望，因为人们，无论过去还是现在，他们想要不可能且矛盾的东西。他们想要更多的食物。他们想要更多的自由。他们想要更低的价格。
They want less government on their backs and telling them what to do. They also want more government, a paternalistic government that is always there with relief and all this kind of thing. They're asking things that no 18th century government can possibly supply. And that will create, that's stoking their expectations to a pitch where the dissatisfaction will explode in fury and disappointment very shortly. Meanwhile, even as they are electing their representatives and drawing up their cahiers, the disorder in France is growing. And this is, again, this doesn't start with the revolution. It precedes the revolution. So effectively, I think what happens is the snow melts as the ice thaws and people go back to the streets. The food prices are still very high. So the disorder returns to the streets and you get a series of reports by about March of food rioting across the country, all the way from Reims in the north to Avignon to Toulouse in the south. And in particular, there is a sense that in the countryside, which is most of France, authority is really breaking down at this point.
他们想要更少的政府干预，告诉他们该做什么。他们也想要更多的政府，一个家长式的政府，总是提供救济和所有这些东西。他们要求的是18世纪的政府根本无法提供的。这将创造——那是在将他们的期望煽动到一种不满将在不久后以愤怒和失望爆发的程度。与此同时，即使在他们选举代表和起草陈情书（cahiers）时，法国的混乱也在加剧。这再次说明，这并不是从革命开始的。它先于革命。所以实际上，我认为发生的事情是，随着冰雪融化，人们回到了街头。食品价格仍然非常高。所以混乱回到了街头，到三月左右，你得到了一系列关于全国各地发生食品骚乱的报告，从北部的兰斯到阿维尼翁，再到南部的图卢兹。特别是，有一种感觉，在乡村——也就是法国的大部分地区——权威在这一点上真的崩溃了。
So I know we've both read Sharma's book. He has this wonderful section, doesn't he, where he introduces this by saying the first mass casualties of the French Revolution of France is rabbits. Because he describes how people just, they're desperate. They form platoons and they go out with guns or whatever, or bludgeons, like British schoolboys. And they're hunting game and rabbits and all this sort of stuff. And this is in contravention of very restrictive game laws.
所以我知道我们都读过夏尔马（Sharma）的书。他有这一段精彩的部分，不是吗？他通过说法国大革命的第一次大规模伤亡是兔子来介绍这一点。因为他描述了人们是如何绝望的。他们组成排，带着枪或其他什么东西，或者像英国男学生那样拿着棍棒。他们在猎取野味和兔子以及所有这些东西。这违反了非常严格的狩猎法。
Yeah. And actually, it's one of the stories of 1789 is the erosion of those game laws. Yeah. And actually, it's one of the stories of 1789, is the erosion of those game laws. And it's bad news for rabbits, and in a very short time, it will be bad news for birds. Yeah, because when gamekeepers try to stop them and say, oi, this is the seigneur's stuff, they're just shooting them dead.
是的。实际上，1789年的故事之一就是这些狩猎法的侵蚀。是的。实际上，1789年的故事之一就是这些狩猎法的侵蚀。这对兔子来说是个坏消息，在很短的时间内，这对鸟类来说也将是个坏消息。是的，因为当猎场看守人试图阻止他们并说，喂，这是领主的东西时，他们只是把他们打死了。
Yeah. But you think the real victims in this are the birds, do you, Tom? I do, really, because they've remained the victims, because it becomes a kind of principle of the new order in France, that you can kill as many birds as you like. That François Mitterrand eating that bird... Absolutely, yeah.
是的。但你认为这其中的真正受害者是鸟类，是吗，汤姆？我确实这么认为，因为它们仍然是受害者，因为这成为了法国新秩序的一种原则，即你可以随心所欲地杀死尽可能多的鸟。弗朗索瓦·密特朗吃那只鸟……绝对是，是的。
It's a slippery slope from bread riots to François Mitterrand biting the head off an innocent bird. Oh no, what a terrible image. So there's a real sense of a power vacuum in the countryside. People are attacking granaries and bakeries. Towns unable to defend themselves are forming their own militias.
从面包骚乱到弗朗索瓦·密特朗咬掉一只无辜鸟的头，这是一个滑坡。噢不，多么可怕的画面。所以乡村里有一种真正的权力真空感。人们正在袭击粮仓和面包店。无法自卫的城镇正在组建自己的民兵。
Yeah. So it's all kind of starting to crumble. But you know what you need in a situation like this? Tell me. You need a massive riot. Yes. Dominic, does such a thing happen? It does. So it happens in Paris. And. Dominic, does such a thing happen? It does.
是的。所以一切都开始崩溃了。但你知道在这种情况下你需要什么吗？告诉我。你需要一场大规模的骚乱。是的。多米尼克，发生了这样的事吗？确实发生了。所以它发生在巴黎。而且。多米尼克，发生了这样的事吗？确实发生了。
So it happens in Paris. And I think, again, I said in the last episode that the French Revolution started in Grenoble. You could also say it. I mean, if you want to choose an alternative date, it starts on the 28th of April, 1789, in Paris, not at the Bastille. So this starts in a place, an area east of the Bastille called the Faubourg, that means neighborhood, Saint-Antoine, Saint-Anthony. And there's a rumor that goes around. There's a big wallpaper manufacturer in town called Réveillon. And there's a rumor that Réveillon had gone to a public meeting and had said that his workers should live on 15 sous a day, which is now the price of a loaf of bread, one loaf only.
所以它发生在巴黎。而且我想，我再次在上一集说过，法国大革命始于格勒诺布尔。你也可以说。我的意思是，如果你想选择一个替代日期，它始于1789年4月28日，在巴黎，而不是在巴士底狱。所以这始于一个地方，巴士底狱东边的一个区域，叫圣安托万郊区（Faubourg Saint-Antoine）。有一个谣言传开了。城里有一个很大的壁纸制造商叫雷韦永（Réveillon）。有传言说雷韦永去参加了一个公开会议，并说他的工人应该每天靠15苏生活，这现在是一个面包的价格，只有一个面包。
And actually, he hadn't said that. What he had said was that if they sorted out the economy and liberalized the economy, there would be lower prices. And then with lower prices, there would be lower wages. And one day, his workers would live on 15 sous a day because bread would be so cheap, or words to that effect. Now, Réveillon is very well known in Paris. He had made, in his capacity as a paper manufacturer, Tom, he had made the paper that was the first balloon, the Montgolfier balloon. And he had sponsored the first hot air balloons, and they had taken off from the yard of his workshop. So, you know, you will see his name if you Google the first hot air balloon flights.
实际上，他并没有那样说。他所说的是，如果他们理顺了经济并自由化了经济，价格就会降低。然后随着价格降低，工资也会降低。有一天，他的工人将靠每天15苏生活，因为面包会变得非常便宜，或者类似的话。现在，雷韦永在巴黎非常出名。他曾以壁纸制造商的身份，汤姆，制作了第一个气球——蒙哥尔费气球（Montgolfier balloon）的纸。他赞助了第一个热气球，它们是从他车间的院子里起飞的。所以，你知道，如果你谷歌第一个热气球飞行，你会看到他的名字。
He is like a really modern, interesting person. He's kind of a James Dyson figure. Yeah, exactly. Entrepreneur, technology. He's a really impressive person, this guy Réveillon. He had been an apprentice paper worker. He'd worked his way up. He'd bought his own paper workshop by the 1780s he's
他就像一个非常现代、有趣的人。他是一个像詹姆斯·戴森（James Dyson）那样的人物。是的，没错。企业家，技术。这个叫雷韦永的人是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。他曾是一名纸张学徒。他一路打拼上来。到18世纪80年代，他买下了自己的造纸车间，他
employing hundreds of workers he's brilliant at making wallpaper and paper generally he's so good he exports it to to england which of course given that england is the sort of yeah colston newcastle yeah it's colston newcastle exactly he's also a very paternalistic employer he pays his workers well more than his competitors and he even pays them over that winter when it's so cold they can't work. He says, I'll sort you out. So he's a saint, a saintly figure from the end of a Dickens novel. A lovely man. Adopting orphans. Mr. Cheerable or something. Anyway, because he's a capitalist entrepreneur, basically everybody hates him because he represents a threat.
雇佣了数百名工人，他非常擅长制作壁纸和纸张。他太出色了，以至于他把它出口到英国，当然，考虑到英国是那种——是的，科尔斯顿（Colston）纽卡斯尔，是的，就是科尔斯顿纽卡斯尔，没错。他也是一个非常家长式的雇主，他给工人的工资比竞争对手高，甚至在那个冬天太冷无法工作时也给他们发工资。他说，我会照顾你们的。所以他是一个圣人，一个来自狄更斯小说结尾的圣人形象。一个可爱的人。收养孤儿。奇尔布尔先生（Mr. Cheerable）之类的。无论如何，因为他是一个资本主义企业家，基本上每个人都恨他，因为他代表了一种威胁。
He represents threatening modernity, putting sort of craftspeople out of work, like his rivals out of work. And so as this story spreads, people in the neighborhood say, yeah, let's go and smash up Réveillon's workshop. The first day they try to do this, some of the local sort of politicians managed to turn them away but the second day the 28th of april the crowd is swelled by unemployed dockers and brewers and tanners and things and about five to ten thousand people turn up outside and do you think this is this is partly like uh in our the election episode that we did um a few weeks back people you know they're told there's going to be a barney oh yeah turn completely out of it yeah but that's the thing about people hearing there's going to be a barney and turning up to see the fun of it or to join in is key to all riots and revolutions i think so all these people turn up and they're basically they lay
他代表了威胁性的现代性，让工匠失业，让他的竞争对手失业。所以随着这个故事的传播，附近的人说，是的，让我们去砸烂雷韦永的车间。第一天他们试图这样做时，一些当地的政客设法把他们赶走了，但第二天，4月28日，人群被失业的码头工人、酿酒工和制革工等壮大，大约五到一万人出现在外面。你认为这部分像我们在几周前做的选举那一集吗，人们，你知道，他们被告知会有一场骚乱，噢是的，完全被吸引出来了，是的，但这就是关于人们听说会有骚乱并出现去看热闹或加入其中的事情，我认为这是所有骚乱和革命的关键。所以所有这些人出现了，他们基本上他们铺开了
siege to his his house and his workshop he and his family managed to get away what then happens is extraordinary it takes these people literally two hours to physically destroy every trace of his house and workshop. They pile up literally everything. And I quote, the furniture, the woodwork, the doors, the linens, the stocks of paper, the carriages, even some poultry. And they set it on fire. So we've had rabbits and now chickens. Chickens, very bad news. A captain from Strasbourg of the guard who came to try and sort of sort out the situation he described 15 or 1600 of the excrement of the nation vomiting up brandy and presenting
围攻他的房子和工作室，他和家人设法逃脱了。接下来发生的事情非同寻常，这些人花了整整两个小时，物理上摧毁了他房子和工作室的每一处痕迹。他们把所有东西都堆在一起。我引用一下：家具、木制品、门、亚麻布、纸张库存、马车，甚至还有一些家禽。然后他们放火烧了。所以我们之前有兔子，现在有鸡了。鸡，非常糟糕的消息。一位来自斯特拉斯堡的卫队队长试图去处理这种情况，他形容那1600名“国家的排泄物”呕吐着白兰地，呈现出
the most disgusting and revolting sight because these people have found what they think is revin's cellar unfortunately what they thought was his wine cellar that he had had thousands of bottles of very good wine that they left untouched what they thought was the cellar of his wine is actually where he's storing the liquids that they used to make the wallpaper so loads of these blokes drink this liquid and they're found dead the next day so you can see why um why the french republic celebrates the anniversary of the french revolution on the 14th of july rather than on the 27th of april with this episode the excrement of the nation, vomiting up brandy. Vomiting up paint stripper.
最令人作呕和反感的景象，因为这些人找到了他们认为是雷韦永酒窖的地方。不幸的是，他们以为那是他的酒窖，里面有成千上万瓶好酒，他们却没动。他们以为是酒窖的地方，实际上是他存放制造壁纸所用液体的地方，所以这些家伙喝了很多这种液体，第二天就被发现死了。所以你可以明白为什么法国共和国在7月14日而不是4月27日庆祝法国大革命周年纪念日。这一集里，“国家的排泄物”呕吐着白兰地。呕吐着脱漆剂。
Yeah, exactly. The city guards arrive too late to sort this out. As in Cronoble, they are pelted with tiles and stones by the crowd, and then they basically lose it and they start shooting into the crowd. And estimates differ massively, but some estimates are that 300 people, that's about the middle ground, about 300 people were killed. And that gives you the bloodiest day of the French Revolution until 1792. So that's the September massacres? Yeah, exactly. I mean, this is a really, really serious business, but of course, completely eclipsed and forgotten now because so much worse is to follow. Well, and I suppose because the main event of the year is looming, or at least
是的，没错。城市卫队赶到时已经太晚了，无法解决这个问题。就像在格勒诺布尔一样，他们被人群用瓦片和石头投掷，然后他们基本上失去了理智，开始向人群开枪。估计数字差异巨大，但一些估计认为有300人死亡，这大约是中间值，约300人丧生。这使得那一天成为法国大革命直到1792年之前最血腥的一天。所以那是九月大屠杀吗？是的，没错。我的意思是，这是一件非常非常严重的事情，但当然，现在完全被掩盖和遗忘了，因为后面发生了更糟糕的事情。嗯，我想是因为这一年的主要事件即将来临，或者至少
the scheduled main event, which is the meeting of the Estates General in Versailles. It is indeed. So after the Réveillon riot, Paris becomes basically an occupied city. Troops are sent in, there are infantry patrols on every street. There are sentries on the street corners. There's cavalry riding up and down the streets. And to the horror of the Parisians, many of these troops are people who have been specially brought in. They are the French armies, German and Hungarian detachments. Basically, of course, in the 18th century,
预定的主要事件，即在凡尔赛召开的三级会议。确实如此。所以在雷韦永骚乱之后，巴黎基本上成了一座被占领的城市。军队被派驻进来，每条街道上都有步兵巡逻。街角有哨兵。骑兵在街道上往来奔驰。令巴黎人感到恐惧的是，许多这些部队是专门调来的。他们是法国军队中的德国和匈牙利分遣队。基本上，当然，在18世纪，
you often recruited troops from elsewhere. As the British did in the American Revolution. As the British did, the Hessians. So to have foreign troops on the streets of Paris for ordinary Parisians is very, very unsettling. And there are all kinds of rumors. There's going to be a coup. There's going to be an insurrection.
你经常从其他地方招募军队。就像英国人在美国独立战争中所做的那样。就像英国人所做的那样，黑森雇佣军。所以对于普通的巴黎人来说，在巴黎街头看到外国军队是非常非常令人不安的。而且有各种各样的谣言。要发生政变了。要发生起义了。
Something is coming. And then, as you said, Tom, at the beginning of May, the Estates General opens in Versailles. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll see what happens. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
有什么事情要发生了。然后，正如你所说的，汤姆，在五月初，三级会议在凡尔赛开幕。好吧，我们休息一下。回来后，我们看看会发生什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往
the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest of history it's all kicking off at versailles where the states general are meeting up and dominic what happens is it all sweetness and history. It's all kicking off at Versailles, where the Estates General are meeting up. And Dominic, what happens? Is it all sweetness and light? Do you know what? It's all fashion, Tom. It's all fashion.
therestisentertainment.com，就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。凡尔赛那边正在如火如荼地进行，三级会议正在召开。多米尼克，发生了什么？一切都是甜美和光明的吗？凡尔赛那边正在如火如荼地进行，三级会议正在召开。多米尼克，发生了什么？一切都是甜美和光明的吗？你知道吗？全是时尚，汤姆。全是时尚。
So, Inter-Armour Sports Citizens, he starts this section with a guy called the Marquis de Ferriere, a lovely French Revolution character. He wrote letters and stuff all through the revolution, so we know what he was thinking. He's a very cultivated, reasonable, public-spirited man from the nobility. So does he survive it? He does survive it, which is nice. It's a relief. He's a man of the Enlightenment. So he's kind of looking forward to this and he thinks, brilliant, we're going to sort out France's problems. But when he arrives in Versailles, what is on his mind is what he is going to wear, because this is not a minor thing. This is an
所以，在“公民们”这一节，他以一个叫费里埃侯爵的人开始，这是一个可爱的法国大革命人物。他在整个革命期间写信等等，所以我们知道他在想什么。他是一位来自贵族阶层、非常有教养、理智且具有公共精神的人。那么他幸存下来了吗？他确实幸存下来了，这很好。这是一种解脱。他是一个启蒙运动时期的人。所以他对此充满期待，他想，太棒了，我们要解决法国的问题。但当他到达凡尔赛时，他脑子里想的是他要穿什么，因为这不是一件小事。这是
important part of the ritual and the politics of the States General. Louis has been giving this some thought, as has his courtiers. He's very anxious about this whole States General thing. His queen, Marie Antoinette, she thinks this is madness. Yeah. She doesn't like Necker either. She hates Necker. She hates the idea of the States General. I mean, she's not wrong. She thinks, opening the door to this, who knows where it will lead. I mean, she's not untrue She thinks opening the door to this, who knows where it will lead.
三级会议仪式和政治的重要组成部分。路易对此进行了一些思考，他的朝臣们也是。他对整个三级会议的事情感到非常焦虑。他的王后玛丽·安托瓦内特认为这简直是疯了。是的。她也不喜欢内克。她讨厌内克。她讨厌三级会议的想法。我的意思是，她没错。她认为，打开这扇门，谁知道会通向哪里。我的意思是，她并非不正确。她认为打开这扇门，谁知道会通向哪里。
I mean, she's not untrue in her political judgments by this point. No. And Louis is very depressed. He's been spending a lot of time messing around with his locks and stuff. And to run the whole thing, he thinks the ideal person would be this guy who's 23 years old. He's called the Marquis de Trebreze. He doesn't know anything about politics, but that's fine. He's really interested in court dress.
我的意思是，她在这一点上的政治判断并非不正确。不。路易非常沮丧。他花了很多时间摆弄他的锁具之类的东西。为了管理这一切，他认为理想的人选会是这个23岁的家伙。他叫特雷布雷兹侯爵。他什么都不懂政治，但这没关系。他真的对宫廷服饰很感兴趣。
Brilliant. And he and Louis decide that in the face of this instability, they need to reinforce a sense of tradition. So he's like the guy that you love on Twitter, who's a big fan of the King of Spain. Derek Guy, the menswear expert. Yeah. He would be a perfect person to run the Estates General.
太棒了。他和路易决定，面对这种不稳定，他们需要加强传统感。所以他就像你在推特上喜欢的那种人，西班牙国王的超级粉丝。德里克·盖，男装专家。是的。他会是管理三级会议的完美人选。
Absolutely. So the Marquis and Louis decide that the nobles, they must dress up, they must wear gold-trimmed cloaks, black silk coats, lace cravats, and they have these special hats, which are made of beaver with white plumes. I mean, beaver fur, not kind of literally a beaver. No, beaver fur.
绝对是。所以侯爵和路易决定，贵族们必须盛装打扮，他们必须穿镶金边的斗篷、黑色丝绸外套、蕾丝领巾，他们还有这些特殊的帽子，是用海狸皮做的，带有白色羽毛。我的意思是，海狸皮，不是字面意义上的海狸。不，海狸皮。
Because that would be horrible. Yeah, it would be horrible. This is about beaver on their heads. Yeah, of course, that would be ridiculous, Tom. Let's be frank because that would be horrible yeah it would be horrible beaver on their head yeah of course that'd be ridiculous tom let's be frank it would be absurd supposedly these beaver fur hats are the same hats that were worn in the reign of henry the fourth who's a great hero isn't he's the people's king he's the people's king now actually this is kind of made up no one really knows what hats they wore but they basically invented a tradition. Well, you never get that in the House of Lords.
因为那太可怕了。是的，那太可怕了。这是关于头上的海狸。是的，当然，那太荒谬了，汤姆。坦白说，因为那太可怕了，是的，那太可怕了，头上的海狸，是的，当然，那太荒谬了，汤姆，坦白说，那太荒唐了。据说这些海狸皮帽子和亨利四世统治时期戴的帽子是一样的，他是一位伟大的英雄，不是吗？他是人民的国王，他是人民的国王。现在实际上这是编造的，没人真正知道他们戴什么帽子，但他们基本上发明了一个传统。好吧，你在上议院永远不会看到这种情况。
So the Marquis de Ferrier gets his cloak and his hat. And on the 4th of May, he joins all the other courtiers and they do a procession with the king and queen through Versailles to the Church of Saint-Louis for the blessing, basically, for the church service that's going to kick the whole thing off. And it could not be a more sumptuous scene. The streets are literally hung with tapestries, sort of draped over the houses, gobbled tapestries. There are big crowds. I mean, they are cheering Mary Antoinette and the king. They shout, long live the king. And so it's a procession that visualizes notions of hierarchy. It does.
所以费里埃侯爵拿到了他的斗篷和帽子。5月4日，他加入了所有其他朝臣的行列，他们与国王和王后一起穿过凡尔赛，前往圣路易教堂进行祈福，基本上就是为了开启整个事情的教堂仪式。这场景再华丽不过了。街道上挂满了挂毯，挂在房子上，戈布兰挂毯。人群很多。我的意思是，他们在为玛丽·安托瓦内特和国王欢呼。他们高喊，国王万岁。所以这是一个将等级观念视觉化的游行。确实。
The monarchy, the nobility, the clergy, the general mass of the people. I think, Tom, it's a bad message to send. It's the wrong message. And actually, Necker had said, could we not have the Estates General in Paris? Because he wanted to get it away from the court for precisely this reason, to avoid giving that impression. But no, they have it in Versailles, they have all their finery, and then come the third estate kind of trailing behind all the commons. And they have been forbidden from dressing up in finery. They have been told, you must wear plain black coats. So Sharma says they look like a convention of apothecaries because they look very kind of sort of solemn. And they look like Puritans from the Lady Bird book about the English Civil War.
君主制、贵族、神职人员、广大民众。我想，汤姆，这是一个糟糕的信息。这是错误的信息。实际上，内克曾说，我们不能在巴黎举行三级会议吗？因为他想把它从宫廷中移开，正是为了这个原因，为了避免给人留下那种印象。但没有，他们在凡尔赛举行，他们穿着所有的华服，然后第三等级的人跟在所有平民后面。他们被禁止穿华服。他们被告知，你们必须穿朴素的黑色外套。所以夏马说他们看起来像药剂师大会，因为他们看起来非常庄重。他们看起来像关于英国革命的莱迪伯德书里的清教徒。
Yeah, kind of dutch burgers in a rembrandt painting dutch burgers exactly but there's one of them in particular who seizes the limelight shama describes him as and i quote a mountain of flesh and muscle crammed with difficulty into black coat and hose his huge face seemed to have been formed by some volcanic eruption that had cooled possibly temporarily into a crust of pumice pitted So more bad skin action. Yeah, that's the key to the French Revolution, isn't it? Bad skin. And this monstrous figure is a fellow who, I imagine you would really like this because you like Lord Byron and you like bad boys.
是的，有点像伦勃朗画中的荷兰市民，荷兰市民没错。但其中有一个人特别引人注目，夏马形容他为，我引用一下，“一座血肉之躯的山，费力地挤进黑色外套和长袜里，他巨大的脸庞似乎是由某种火山喷发形成的，冷却后，可能暂时形成了一层浮石外壳，坑坑洼洼的。”所以更多糟糕的皮肤状况。是的，这就是法国大革命的关键，不是吗？糟糕的皮肤。而这个怪物般的人物是一个家伙，我想你会非常喜欢这个，因为你喜欢拜伦勋爵，你喜欢坏男孩。
He's Honoré Gabriel Ricchetti, Comte de Mirabeau. So I would say that the history of the French Revolution could be written as being about Gérard Depardieu characters. Yeah. So Danton would be another example. This is a man who would be played by Gerard Depardieu and alternated with very thin, sinister-looking people. Who are Robespierre and people of that ilk. So Mirabeau is such a...
他是奥诺雷·加布里埃尔·里凯蒂，米拉波伯爵。所以我认为法国大革命的历史可以写成是关于杰拉尔·德帕迪约式角色的历史。是的。所以丹东会是另一个例子。这是一个会被杰拉尔·德帕迪约扮演的人，并与非常瘦、看起来阴险的人交替出现。比如罗伯斯庇尔和那一类人。所以米拉波是一个如此……
When I did this for A-Level, he seemed such a dull dog. Always talking about like... Constitutions. Electoral, yeah, constitutional procedures and stuff. I mean, I just couldn't wait to get past Mirabeau and onto Robespierre and Marow and stuff. But actually, he's a tremendously interesting character. He's a really badly behaved, sort of posh wastrel. But he's also, Dominic, he's like your hero, Stanley Baldwin, because he's an enthusiast for writing pornography.
当我做A-Level的时候，他看起来像个沉闷的家伙。总是谈论像……宪法。选举，是的，宪法程序之类的。我的意思是，我简直迫不及待地想跳过米拉波，去看罗伯斯庇尔和马拉之类的。但实际上，他是一个非常有趣的人物。他是一个行为非常糟糕、有点时髦的败家子。但他也是，多米尼克，他就像你的英雄斯坦利·鲍德温，因为他是一个写色情作品的狂热分子。
Yes. I would imagine Stanley Baldwin's work was a lot more tame than Mirabeau's. So Mirabeau was a great philanderer, which Stanley Baldwin was not. He was very profligate, again, a big contrast. His father had him put in prison. His wife took him to court. So that's quite Marquis de Sade behaviour. He's very Marquis de Sade-like, actually.
是的。我想斯坦利·鲍德温的作品比米拉波的要温和得多。所以米拉波是一个伟大的风流才子，而斯坦利·鲍德温不是。他非常挥霍，这又是一个巨大的对比。他父亲把他关进了监狱。他妻子把他告上了法庭。所以这相当有萨德侯爵的行为。他确实非常像萨德侯爵。
He's writing this pornography, but he's also writing very vicious political polemics. So he accuses his own estate, the nobility. He says 30,000 calculating vampires who have sucked the blood of 20 million Frenchmen. And it will amaze you to know that having written that, he doesn't manage to win election from the rest of the nobility. But the good news is that he can run for the third estate, which he does. And he's elected from Aix-en-Provence. The thing is that despite his appearance, he's basically a huge man when he's got this terrible skin and he's shouting about vampires and stuff. But actually behind all that, he's quite moderate. He wants the kind of British constitution.
他在写这种色情作品，但他也在写非常恶毒的政治论战。所以他指责他自己的阶层，贵族。他说“30000个吸血鬼，吸干了2000万法国人的血”。你会惊讶地发现，写了这些之后，他没能从其他贵族那里赢得选举。但好消息是他可以竞选第三等级，他也确实这么做了。他从普罗旺斯地区艾克斯当选。问题是，尽管他的外表，他基本上是一个巨大的男人，皮肤很糟糕，还在大喊大叫关于吸血鬼之类的事情。但实际上在这一切背后，他相当温和。他想要那种英国式的宪法。
He totally wants the British constitution. And that's very sensible and reflects well on him. But he is determined to be seen as the supreme champion of the people in this whole imbroglio. So when they have that procession, he walks in a peculiar way, throwing his head back so that everyone can see this huge head and sort of bobbing his head around
他完全想要英国式的宪法。这非常明智，对他评价很好。但他决心在整个混乱中被视为人民的最高捍卫者。所以当他们进行那次游行时，他以一种奇怪的方式行走，向后仰着头，这样每个人都能看到这个巨大的头，并有点晃动他的头
in a slightly disturbing manner. So he's like Harry Maguire. Yes, he's got Harry Maguire's head. Exactly. And if you don't know who Harry Maguire is... Harry Maguire crossed with a volcano. Yes. So people are interested in the football metaphor. My brother once described Martin Keown, the football pundit, as looking like a fish trapped
以一种稍微令人不安的方式。所以他就像哈里·马奎尔。是的，他有哈里·马奎尔的头。没错。如果你不知道哈里·马奎尔是谁……哈里·马奎尔和火山的结合体。是的。所以人们对足球隐喻很感兴趣。我哥哥曾经形容足球评论员马丁·基翁看起来像一条被困在
in a meteor. And that is Mirabeau's face. A couple of other good characters from the third estate. You've got Siez, the abbé who wrote What's the Third Estate? There's our friend from Grenoble, Mr. Meunier, the first revolutionary. Yeah, the young judge. And there's an obscure young lawyer from Arras who's called Maximilien Robespierre.
流星里的鱼。这就是米拉波的脸。第三等级还有几个好角色。你有西哀士，写了《什么是第三等级？》的修道院院长。还有我们来自格勒诺布尔的朋友，梅尼耶先生，第一位革命者。是的，那位年轻的法官。还有一个来自阿拉斯的默默无闻的年轻律师，叫马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。
So he is the counterpoint to Mirabeau. Yeah. Thin. Pale. He's me. Mirabeau is you. Thanks, Tom. I'd take Mirabeau.
所以他是米拉波的对照。是的。瘦。苍白。他是你。米拉波是你。谢谢，汤姆。我会选米拉波。
Yeah, you'd rather be Mirabeau than rose pierre i mean it's terrible that my physical form means that i have to play rose pierre yeah but robespierre is more typical of the people in the third estate because they're basically all lawyers yeah of 600 of them 180 are lawyers and 220 judges or magistrates so in other words this third estate people the common so-called they're not the common people of France. They are upwardly mobile winners, people who actually are not very representative of the mass of the French people, but people who are incredibly articulate and ambitious. And resentful of those above them. Yeah, and the trouble is that those above them don't make any effort to hide that they're above them or to include them. Well, isn't that the whole point of the Ancien Régime?
是的，你宁愿是米拉波而不是罗伯斯庇尔。我的意思是，我的外形意味着我必须扮演罗伯斯庇尔，这太糟糕了。是的，但罗伯斯庇尔更典型地代表了第三等级的人，因为他们基本上都是律师。是的，600人中有180人是律师，220人是法官或地方法官。所以换句话说，这些第三等级的人，所谓的平民，他们不是法国的普通民众。他们是向上流动的赢家，实际上并不是法国大众的代表，而是非常善于表达且雄心勃勃的人。而且对上面的人心怀怨恨。是的，问题在于上面的人并没有做出任何努力来掩盖他们高高在上的事实，或者去包容他们。好吧，这不就是旧制度的全部意义吗？
It's all about hierarchy. Of course it is. So that was 4th of May, the procession. And 5th of May, they meet in the Salle des Menus Plaisir, the Hall of the Lesser Pleasures of Versailles. And Louis is on his throne. He's got Marie Antoinette at his side. There's a table for his ministers.
这全是关于等级制度的。当然是。所以那是5月4日的游行。5月5日，他们在凡尔赛的“小娱乐厅”开会。路易坐在他的王座上。玛丽·安托瓦内特在他身边。有一张桌子给他的大臣们。
Then you have the benches of the church and the nobility. And then the third estate are all shoved down have the benches of the church and the nobility. And then the third estate are all shoved down to the far end of the hall. And the king gives a speech and he says, ah, brilliant. You're all here. I've been looking forward to this. Everyone's great. Should have done it before. He does say there's been a lot of talk of innovations. I think this is much exaggerated. I don't want to hear any more of that. Then there's a strange business with his hat. So he doffs his hat at the end of the speech, and then the nobility doff their hats. Their beaver hats.
然后是教会和贵族的长椅。然后第三等级都被挤到大厅的最远端。国王发表了演讲，他说，啊，太棒了。你们都到了。我一直很期待这个。每个人都很棒。早该这么做了。他确实说有很多关于创新的讨论。我认为这被大大夸大了。我不想再听到这些了。然后发生了一件关于他帽子的奇怪事情。他在演讲结束时脱下帽子，然后贵族们脱下他们的帽子。他们的海狸皮帽子。
Their beaver hats, exactly. Now, the third estate are confused at this. Some of them take their hats off or put their hats on or whatever. Their hats are going on and off. And this is against all protocol. They shouldn't be doing anything with their hats. Louis is really confused. He has to take his hat back off again. They all start putting their hats off and then on. But, Dominic, it's fine, isn't it? Because despite all the confusion,
他们的海狸皮帽子，没错。现在，第三等级对此感到困惑。他们中的一些人脱下帽子或戴上帽子之类的。他们的帽子戴上又脱下。这违反了所有礼仪。他们不应该对帽子做任何事情。路易真的很困惑。他不得不再次把帽子脱下来。他们都开始脱下帽子，然后又戴上。但是，多米尼克，这没关系，不是吗？因为尽管有所有的混乱，
there's then the huge excitement of Jacques Necker giving a speech on fiscal policy and finance. So that must cheer them all up. Well, everyone's really looking forward to this. So this is the moment when the great man, the Swiss banker, is going to put everything to rights. And he stands up and he reads the first half hour of his speech. And then he says, listen, there's two and a half hours more of this to go. I can't be bothered to read it myself.
接下来是雅克·内克发表关于财政政策和金融的演讲的巨大兴奋。所以那一定让他们都振作起来了。好吧，每个人都很期待这个。所以这是这位伟大的瑞士银行家将把一切理顺的时刻。他站起来，读了他演讲的前半小时。然后他说，听着，还有两个半小时要读。我自己读太麻烦了。
And he gives it to the secretary of the agriculture committee and says, you read it. And the guy from the agriculture committee has been chosen just because he has a very loud and strident voice. And he reads, and Necker has basically written an incredibly boring speech about the deficit and about finance. Because the king starts yawning, doesn't he? And everyone starts falling asleep.
他把它交给农业委员会的秘书，说，你来读。而那个农业委员会的人被选中仅仅是因为他有一个非常响亮和刺耳的声音。他读着，内克基本上写了一篇关于赤字和金融的极其无聊的演讲。因为国王开始打哈欠了，不是吗？每个人都开始睡着了。
People fall asleep. Everybody says afterwards, oh my God, it's so disappointing. What a useless person Necker is. I've totally changed my mind. So a bit like the British general election, the recent British general election. Very significant, but boring. Yes, it's so disappointing. What a useless person Necker is. I've totally changed my mind. So a bit like the British general election, the recent British general election. Very significant, but boring. Yes, I guess so.
人们睡着了。每个人事后都说，哦天哪，太令人失望了。内克真是个没用的人。我完全改变了主意。所以有点像英国大选，最近的英国大选。非常重要，但很无聊。是的，太令人失望了。内克真是个没用的人。我完全改变了主意。所以有点像英国大选，最近的英国大选。非常重要，但很无聊。是的，我想是这样。
The next day, the 6th of May, they all have to arrive and they're going to begin their deliberations. And first of all, the various estates have to be registered, have to verify their credentials. And when they all arrive, the king's men say, right, you're going to go to your separate chambers. Nobility over here, clergy over here, third estate this way.
第二天，5月6日，他们都必须到达，他们要开始审议。首先，各个等级必须登记，必须验证他们的资格。当他们都到达时，国王的人说，好了，你们要去你们各自的议事厅。贵族这边，神职人员这边，第三等级走这边。
And Mirabeau says, stop. We cannot go to a separate chamber. Because once we agree to that principle, the idea of all sitting together and us dominating is lost. We must verify our credentials with everybody else. And he is really passionate about it. And one of the deputies says, he's like a ferocious beast, an oranger. He speaks in convulsions. His face is contorted. He spits out his words in a fury. And that obviously is the French revolutionary style. Everything is overwrought. You weigh your sentiments physically
米拉波说，停下。我们不能去各自的议事厅。因为一旦我们同意那个原则，所有人坐在一起、我们占据主导地位的想法就消失了。我们必须与其他人一起验证我们的资格。他对此非常充满激情。其中一位代表说，他就像一只凶猛的野兽，一个演说家。他说话时浑身抽搐。他的脸扭曲了。他愤怒地吐出他的话语。这显然是法国革命的风格。一切都过火了。你物理上权衡你的情感
and you turn your rhetoric up to the absolute maximum. And yet there is also a sense, isn't there, that you're trying to emulate a Roman style, a kind of Ciceronian style. Yeah, definitely there is. Formal and faintly chilly. Well, I think there's a couple of things actually. So part of it is definitely these people have studied the classical period at school, haven't they? These young lawyers. Rob Spierre, the classic example. They've read all the speeches, particularly Cicero, and they're obsessed with Cicero and copying Cicero's rhetoric. So they see themselves as the new Romans. But also there is an argument that it's been a great age the last 10, 20 years in France of the public theatre, popular theatre. Well, we talked about how massively important the theatre is a couple of episodes ago with
并将你的修辞调到最大值。然而，也有一种感觉，不是吗，你在试图模仿罗马风格，一种西塞罗式的风格。是的，绝对有。正式且略带寒意。好吧，我认为实际上有几件事。所以部分原因是这些人确实在学校里学习过古典时期，不是吗？这些年轻的律师。罗伯斯庇尔，典型的例子。他们读过所有的演讲，特别是西塞罗的，他们痴迷于西塞罗并模仿西塞罗的修辞。所以他们把自己看作新的罗马人。但也有一个论点是，过去10、20年是法国公共剧院、大众剧院的伟大时代。好吧，我们几集前谈到了剧院是多么重要，
The Marriage of Figaro. Yeah, The Marriage a Figaro is a perfect example because The Marriage of a Figaro is very emotional, tear-stained, over-the-top, fun, this sense of spectacle. And for the first time, really, politics is deliberately emulating that. So there is a public gallery of the deliberations. The Third Estate are basically having a massive stalemate with the court and refusing to go ahead and be verified along with the other chambers and this stalemate continues and every day you know thousands of people will get coaches from paris come out to versailles to watch the show the most famous one is an english traveler called arthur young who is one of the great go-to
《费加罗的婚礼》。是的，《费加罗的婚礼》是一个完美的例子，因为《费加罗的婚礼》非常感人、泪流满面、夸张、有趣，这种奇观感。这是第一次，政治在刻意模仿这一点。所以审议有一个公共画廊。第三等级基本上与宫廷陷入了巨大的僵局，拒绝继续并与其他议事厅一起验证，这种僵局持续着，每天你知道成千上万的人会从巴黎坐马车来到凡尔赛观看表演。最著名的是一位名叫阿瑟·杨的英国旅行者，他是早期法国大革命最伟大的参考
sources on the early french revolution he's quoted in every single book. And he gets a coach out there. He has all the big names speaking. He's excited about all the oratory. And he says what's shocking for him, coming from Britain, is that the spectators in the galleries clap and cheer and boo as though it is a play. And he says, this is very bad. This is reducing politics to mere entertainment. But actually, this becomes central to the revolution, emotional outpourings. And this idea of the orator, who is copying Roman models like Cicero, commanding people by the strength of his voice. So Mirabeau had a really good voice, perhaps bursting into tears while he's talking, which people think is brilliant. But also presumably it's because unlike in Britain, where you have the House of Commons, you have the House of Lords and you have elections where
来源之一，他在每一本书中都被引用。他坐马车去了那里。他有所有的大人物在演讲。他对所有的演说感到兴奋。他说对他来说令人震惊的是，来自英国，画廊里的观众鼓掌、欢呼和嘘声，就像在看戏一样。他说，这非常糟糕。这把政治降格为纯粹的娱乐。但实际上，这成为了革命的核心，情感的宣泄。以及这种模仿西塞罗等罗马模式的演说家的想法，通过他声音的力量指挥人们。所以米拉波有一个非常好的声音，也许在说话时泪流满面，人们认为这很棒。但大概也是因为不像在英国，你有下议院，你有上议院，你有选举，
people go on the hustings. And so the traditions of political engagement are organic. They've evolved. They're not suddenly being portrayed to people as something new. In this occasion, no one's seen anything like this. Yeah, of course. They don't have regular elections. They don't have the throwing of dead cats and the attacks with halberds that are such an important part of the British constitution. And so there must be a feeling that Mirabeau and everybody else is kind of feeling their way into roles that have not yet been defined.
人们去竞选。所以政治参与的传统是有机的。它们已经进化了。它们不是突然被描绘成新事物。在这种情况下，没有人见过这样的事情。是的，当然。他们没有定期的选举。他们没有英国宪法中非常重要的扔死猫和用戟攻击的行为。所以一定有一种感觉，米拉波和其他所有人都在摸索着进入尚未定义的角色。
Yeah, making it up. What is politics? And what is the style of politics? What is the style of politics? Exactly. And they're drawing their style of politics from the theatre, from literature, from the kind of cultural mood of the time. And so this is clearly very much true of the members of the Third Estate, that they are
是的，编造它。什么是政治？政治的风格是什么？政治的风格是什么？没错。他们从剧院、文学、当时的文化氛围中汲取政治风格。所以这显然非常适用于第三等级的成员，他们
playing a role simply by not moving, by sticking to their guns. What about the First and Second Estates? They must be watching this performance as well and thinking, maybe we should join it. Yeah, eventually. They don't join straight away though. There's about a month before the first dribs and drabs from them come to join the Third Estate. So the stalemate is quite long lasting. And in all that time, the stalemate is being reported back in Paris. So Mirabeau, for example, his mistress owns a print shop, which is very convenient for him because he writes letters to his constituents telling them what's going on. And they go to the printers and they're released in Paris before they even get back to Aix-en-Provence.
仅仅通过不动、坚持立场就在扮演一个角色。第一和第二等级呢？他们一定也在观看这场表演，并想，也许我们应该加入。是的，最终。不过他们没有马上加入。在大约一个月后，他们才开始有零星的人加入第三等级。所以僵局持续了很长时间。在这段时间里，僵局被传回巴黎。所以米拉波，例如，他的情妇拥有一家印刷厂，这对他来说非常方便，因为他写信给他的选民告诉他们发生了什么。它们被送到印刷厂，在它们甚至还没回到普罗旺斯地区艾克斯之前就在巴黎发布了。
So there's this stream of stuff. So actually, it's not just a theatrical. So there's this stream of stuff. So actually, it's not just a theatrical event. It's also a media event. Yeah, of course. The first mediated, mediatized political event of its kind. Because there's this whole thing, isn't there, that Robert Danton mentions about how people wear buttons with images of top political actors and things. So there is a sense in which the relationship of the people to the theatre can be mapped onto their relationship to what is going on in Versailles. Yeah, I think that's definitely true. There is a sense that it's an entertainment,
所以有一连串的东西。所以实际上，这不仅仅是一个戏剧性的。所以有一连串的东西。所以实际上，这不仅仅是一个戏剧性的事件。它也是一个媒体事件。是的，当然。同类中第一个被中介化、媒体化的政治事件。因为有这一切，不是吗，罗伯特·丹东提到的关于人们如何佩戴带有顶级政治演员图像的徽章之类的事情。所以人们与剧院的关系可以在某种程度上映射到他们与凡尔赛正在发生的事情的关系上。是的，我认为这绝对是真的。有一种感觉，这是一种娱乐，
it's a spectacle, it's a sport, it's a fashion. And of course, it's of pressing importance because of the catastrophic state that people are in across the country and in Paris as well. Absolutely. So by the end of May, early June, there are really, really bleak apocalyptic reports coming in from the countryside. There are posters going up in Paris saying that if nothing changes, there's going to be an insurrection. You can imagine the scene, calling for an uprising, those kind of posters. And that lends an urgency to all this.
这是一种奇观，这是一种运动，这是一种时尚。当然，由于全国各地以及巴黎的灾难性状况，这具有紧迫的重要性。绝对是。所以到五月底、六月初，从农村传来了非常非常凄凉的末日报告。巴黎贴出了海报，说如果什么都不改变，就会发生起义。你可以想象那个场景，呼吁起义，那种海报。这给这一切增加了紧迫感。
So on the 10th of June, the Abbé Siez says, look, we cannot wait any longer. The courts seem determined to not let us sit with the other states. Here's what we do. We will give them an ultimatum. You come and sit with us. And whether they do or not, we will declare ourselves the National Assembly. We will be the sole representatives of the nation and we will take the nation's fate into our hands." This is an unbelievable thing. It is. They're in Versailles. The monarch is only hundreds of yards away in some other room and they're basically saying, we will take this into our own hands. But also they're laying claim to the sovereignty that traditionally has been that of the monarch. Exactly.
所以6月10日，西哀士修道院院长说，看，我们不能再等了。宫廷似乎决心不让我们与其他等级坐在一起。我们这样做。我们将给他们最后通牒。你们来和我们坐在一起。无论他们是否这样做，我们将宣布自己为国民议会。我们将是国家的唯一代表，我们将把国家的命运掌握在自己手中。”这是一件令人难以置信的事情。确实是。他们在凡尔赛。君主就在几百码外的另一个房间里，他们基本上在说，我们将把这掌握在自己手中。但他们也声称拥有传统上属于君主的主权。没错。
So at this point, I don't think they recognize that, do they? Well, I think they still think this is kind of going to be a rerun of Britain's glorious revolution. And it won't go too far. Eventually, Louis will give in and it'll be all fine. I think a lot of them still do think that. And you asked, Tom, and I didn't answer it properly, for which I apologize to you, hand on heart, about the first two estates. Some of them are now beginning to come across. On the 13th of June, there was Some of them are now beginning to come across.
所以在这个时候，我不认为他们意识到了这一点，对吧？好吧，我想他们仍然认为这会是英国光荣革命的重演。它不会走得太远。最终，路易会屈服，一切都会好起来的。我想他们中的许多人仍然那样认为。你问了，汤姆，我没有正确回答，我向你道歉，真心实意地，关于前两个等级。他们中的一些人现在开始过来了。6月13日，有
On the 13th of June, there was a real breakthrough. Some parish priests come across. And actually, the first estate, the clergy, they are actually the ones who are closest to the mass of ordinary French men and women. Because most of the clergy's deputies are not archbishops with kind of sumptuous Cardinal Woolsey style robes. They're ordinary parish priests. Who are often very poor themselves. Very poor and who actually understand the peasants better
6月13日，出现了一个真正的突破。一些教区牧师过来了。实际上，第一等级，神职人员，他们实际上是与广大普通法国男女最接近的人。因为大多数神职人员的代表不是那种穿着华丽红衣主教风格长袍的大主教。他们是普通的教区牧师。他们自己通常也非常贫穷。非常贫穷，而且实际上比一些第三等级的律师更了解农民。
than some of the third estate lawyers do. So more and more of these priests come over in the next few days, rising to about 100 of the priests. And on the 17th of June, they say, enough time has run out. We are going to now call ourselves, as it were, a National Assembly. The amusing thing is they can't decide what the name should be. So Siez says, our title, which will resound down the generations, is the Known and Verifiable Representatives.
所以越来越多的这些牧师在接下来的几天里过来了，增加到大约100名牧师。6月17日，他们说，够了，时间到了。我们现在要称自己为，姑且称之为，国民议会。有趣的是，他们无法决定名字应该是什么。所以西哀士说，我们的头衔，将响彻后代，是“已知且可验证的代表”。
So this is very like us trying to decide what to call episodes of our podcast. It's actually like you wanting the podcast to be called Podpast. I still regret that. Yeah. Yeah. You're about to stick with that. And this is the first time I've ever heard you say that you regret it. I just think it would have been a very good name, but whatever.
所以这很像我们试图决定我们的播客剧集叫什么名字。这实际上很像你想让播客叫“Podpast”。我仍然后悔那个。是的。是的。你打算坚持那个。这是我第一次听到你说你后悔。我只是觉得那会是一个很好的名字，但不管怎样。
Oh, sorry. You don't regret having come up with it? No, not at all. No, I'm very proud of it. Well, so Amunier, the guy from Grenoble, he says that's a terrible name, the known for our representatives. He says, I've got a very catchy name. He's the Tom Holland of the Third Estate.
哦，抱歉。你不后悔想出它吗？不，一点也不。不，我为此感到非常自豪。好吧，所以梅尼耶，那个来自格勒诺布尔的家伙，他说那是个糟糕的名字，“已知的代表”。他说，我有一个非常朗朗上口的名字。他是第三等级的汤姆·霍兰德。
He's got a brilliant name. I think we should be called the Legitimate Assembly of the Representatives of the Larger Part of the Nation Acting in the Absence of the Smaller Part. No, I'm about compression. Pod passed. Anyway, listen, let's not get into that. So they have a succession of terrible names, but eventually they decide let's go for National Assembly.
他有一个出色的名字。我认为我们应该被称为“在较小部分缺席的情况下，代表国家较大部分的合法议会”。不，我喜欢压缩。Pod passed。不管怎样，听着，我们别谈那个了。所以他们有一连串糟糕的名字，但最终他们决定选择“国民议会”。
Let's cut to the chase. They eventually said, let's just call it the National Assembly. Now, there's a sense, I think, at this point of them self-radicalising anything being possible. They say that basically all existing taxation is illegal because they haven't authorised it. But for the time being, they're happy to let the existing taxes continue until they have drawn up the new, remember, they, not the king, have drawn up the new tax system. So this is, as you said, I mean, they're seizing sovereignty. It is really an incredible thing. Louis is very, very deeply depressed during all this. I mean, he's got, as you said, Tom, quite large, he's eating a lot, he's messing around
直奔主题吧。他们最终说，就叫它国民议会吧。现在，我认为在这一点上，他们有一种自我激进化的感觉，任何事情都有可能发生。他们说基本上所有现有的税收都是非法的，因为他们没有授权。但目前，他们很高兴让现有的税收继续，直到他们起草了新的，记住，是他们，而不是国王，起草了新的税收制度。所以正如你所说，我的意思是，他们在夺取主权。这确实是一件令人难以置信的事情。路易在这一切期间非常非常沮丧。我的意思是，正如你所说，汤姆，他相当大，他吃了很多，他在摆弄
with his locks. he feels very sad that this is spiraling out of control and then a terrible thing happens doesn't it the dofa his his son his much-loved son dies on the 4th of june dies of tb and actually dies we won't go into all the details because i think actually it's unnecessary and horrible but his this little boy dies a very agonizing lingering death from tb he's just seven years old and louis and marie antoinette are understandably absolutely distraught and in a weird way actually i think almost all the history books even the best ones underplay this they just say oh by the way his son died and he's very upset and he withdraws. But I mean, this for him is a loss of unbelievable proportions,
他的锁具。他感到非常难过，因为这一切正在失控，然后发生了一件可怕的事情，不是吗？王太子，他的儿子，他深爱的儿子在6月4日去世了，死于肺结核，实际上死于……我们不会深入所有细节，因为我认为实际上这是不必要的和可怕的，但他的这个小男孩死于肺结核，非常痛苦、漫长的死亡，他才七岁，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特理所当然地感到非常痛苦，而且奇怪的是，实际上我认为几乎所有的历史书，即使是最好的书，都淡化了这一点，他们只是说，哦，顺便说一下，他的儿子死了，他非常难过，然后他退出了。但我的意思是，这对他来说是难以置信的损失，
just horrendous. Because unusually for a French king, he hasn't had a mistress. He's very much a family man. And Marie Antoinette as well is a very good mother. So they are engaged with their children in a way that is unusual, but reflects the kind of sentimental ideas of Rousseau. Yeah, absolutely. So he withdraws from public business. He physically leaves Versailles for his country estate at Marlis-le-Roi, and there he is lost in mourning. So he's not taking charge of all this. It's spiralling out of control. When he finally rouses himself and comes back to Versailles,
简直太可怕了。因为对于法国国王来说，他没有情妇，这很不寻常。他非常顾家。玛丽·安托瓦内特也是一位非常好的母亲。所以他们以一种不寻常的方式与他们的孩子互动，但这反映了卢梭的那种感伤思想。是的，绝对是。所以他退出了公共事务。他物理上离开了凡尔赛，去了他在马利勒鲁瓦的乡村庄园，在那里他沉浸在哀悼中。所以他没有负责这一切。它正在失控。当他最终振作起来回到凡尔赛时，
he has a big meeting with Necker and with his brothers, who are much more hardline than he is, and with the Queen. What on earth are we going to do? And Necker says, I think we should probably give in to the third estate at this point. We've got to meet them halfway. And Marie Antoinette and his brothers say, this business has gone massively out of control. It's Necker's fault. We should shut all this down now. And Louis can't decide. So what he does is a typical Louis thing of a bit of change,
他和内克以及他的兄弟们（他们比他更强硬）以及王后进行了一次大会议。我们到底该怎么办？内克说，我认为我们现在可能应该向第三等级屈服。我们必须在半路与他们会合。玛丽·安托瓦内特和他的兄弟们说，这件事已经完全失控了。这是内克的错。我们现在应该关闭这一切。路易无法决定。所以他做了一件典型的路易式的事情，做了一点改变，
but not too much, which doesn't satisfy anybody. He says, I'll bring all the estates together in what he calls a séance real, a grand meeting, and I'll offer them some reforms, but they have to abandon all this rubbish and tosh about a national assembly like this is no good so i want to have this big meeting and they're going to have it in the hall where the third estate had been meeting and they have to set it up they literally have to set up the room on the morning of the 20th of june his work men go in to build the platforms necessary for this meeting, where he is going to lay down the law. Meanwhile, they put up signs outside saying, the third estate can't meet here today. We're setting up the room for this big meeting.
但不多，这不能满足任何人。他说，我将把所有等级召集在一起，进行他所谓的“皇家会议”，我会给他们提供一些改革，但他们必须放弃所有关于国民议会的垃圾和废话，这没用，所以我想要举行这个大会，他们将在第三等级开会的大厅里举行，他们必须布置它，他们必须在6月20日的早上布置房间，他的工人们进去建造这次会议所需的平台，他将在那里制定法律。同时，他们在外面贴出告示说，第三等级今天不能在这里开会。我们正在为这次大会布置房间。
And he puts guards outside. The third estate all arrive to find the doors are closed and there are guards blocking the way and there are signs coming up about a big meeting with the king and there are hundreds of armed guards standing around blocking their way and it is also pouring with rain so they're all getting soaked and they expected to go into the hall and have their meeting what are they gonna do and lots of them say well i'm not just going to go home to bed. We should have our meeting on our own as the National Assembly, as normal. And one of them, a man called Dr. Geek. Tom, you love this.
他在外面安排了警卫。第三等级都到了，发现门关着，有警卫挡路，有关于国王大会的告示，有数百名武装警卫站在周围挡住他们的路，而且还下着倾盆大雨，所以他们都湿透了，他们本以为可以进入大厅开会，他们该怎么办？他们中的许多人说，好吧，我不会就这样回家睡觉。我们应该像往常一样，以国民议会的身份自己开会。其中一个人，一个叫吉约坦医生的人。汤姆，你喜欢这个。
Well, I love the way that much-loved characters and indeed implements of execution are kind of subtly introduced in unexpected angled ways. So what's the name of this doctor? Dr. Guillotin, who is mindful of interesting devices, Tom. Rational devices for law and order. Dr. Guillotin says, oh, a friend of mine owns a tennis court around the corner. We could go and meet there. It's in the Rue du Vieux Versailles, the old Versailles Street. Now, often you read popular accounts and they say,
好吧，我喜欢那种深受喜爱的角色，甚至是处决工具，以意想不到的角度被巧妙地引入的方式。那么这位医生的名字是什么？吉约坦医生，他很在意有趣的装置，汤姆。用于法律和秩序的理性装置。吉约坦医生说，哦，我的一个朋友在拐角处有一个网球场。我们可以去那里开会。它在旧凡尔赛街。现在，你经常读到大众的叙述，他们说，
the Royal Tennis Court at Versailles. That's not right at all. The game that is being played is a game called Real Tennis, Jeu de Paume in French. But it's not the king's court or anything like it. It's some friend of Dr. Guillotin's who owns the court. Anyway, they all pile into this tennis court.
凡尔赛的皇家网球场。那根本不对。正在进行的比赛叫作皇家网球，法语叫Jeu de Paume。但这并不是国王的球场或类似的地方。球场的主人是吉约坦医生的一位朋友。总之，他们全都挤进了这个网球场。
So a real tennis is a little bit like squash, but with a very hard ball. So it's indoors. It's kind of an echoey, very stark, like a squash court. They're all soaked with the rain. They all pile into this place. It's very plain, very drab drab very stark but actually that kind of
皇家网球有点像壁球，但球非常硬。它是在室内进行的。球场回声很大，非常简陋，就像壁球场一样。他们都被雨淋透了。他们全都挤进这个地方。这里非常朴素、单调、简陋，但实际上那种环境
suits them it does because it's it's classical isn't it potentially it is and it gives them perfect opportunity to swear an oath yeah because munier the man from grenoble he says what we should all do is we should now swear an oath now they've all used to this because the big hit painting of the last few years was by david who you'll be talking about in a subsequent later episode won't you one day yeah when we finally get around to finishing this huge french revolution epic david had done a painting called the oath of the heresie hadn't he about three brothers who sacrificed themselves for rome or offered to sacrifice themselves for rome so martyrs patriots and they all decide they want to copy this painting.
很适合他们，确实如此，因为它很古典，不是吗？可能确实是这样，这给了他们宣誓的绝佳机会。是的，因为来自格勒诺布尔的穆尼耶说，我们现在应该做的是宣誓。他们对此都很熟悉，因为过去几年最轰动的画作是达维特画的，你会在后续的某一集里谈到他，对吧？是的，当我们最终完成这部宏大的法国大革命史诗时。达维特画过一幅叫《贺拉斯兄弟之誓》的画，不是吗？讲的是三兄弟为罗马牺牲自己，或者说主动提出为罗马牺牲，也就是烈士、爱国者，他们都决定要模仿这幅画。
So they swear an oath to God and the patrie, the fatherland. They will never separate until they've written a new constitution for France. And they say, listen, we don't even need a palace or a courtroom because we are the National Assembly, and the National Assembly will exist wherever we come together. And then they raise their arms as in david's painting they stretch out their right arms not not often not a brilliant look to be fair tainted by subsequent uh misconduct in the 20th century but that's by the by they stretch out their right arms they put out the other hand on their heart and they swear
于是他们向上帝和祖国宣誓。在为法国写出一部新宪法之前，他们绝不分离。他们说，听着，我们甚至不需要宫殿或法庭，因为我们就是国民议会，只要我们聚在一起，国民议会就存在。然后他们像达维特画中那样举起手臂，伸出右手——说实话，这姿势不太好看，被20世纪随后的不当行为玷污了，但那是题外话——他们伸出右手，另一只手放在心口，宣誓
this oath a great act of theatre again. Classic act of theatre inspired by a painting. The media, by paintings. And the subsequent engravings that reproduce the painting. There's incredible kind of meta self-consciousness about the whole thing. There is, exactly. Everybody's, what do they call it? Cosplaying.
这个誓言又是一场伟大的戏剧表演。经典的戏剧表演，灵感来自绘画。媒体，通过绘画。以及复制这幅画的后续版画。整个事情有一种令人难以置信的元自我意识。确实，正是如此。每个人都在，他们管这叫什么？角色扮演。
That's what they're doing, isn't it? They're basically dressing up and pretending to be Romans. The news spreads very quickly. They've sworn this oath in this tennis court. There are printed copies of the oath on sale in Paris the next morning. Louis' brothers and the other hardliners in the court go absolutely ballistic at this. I love their solution to the whole problem. The Comte de La Troye, he just says, brilliant, I'll just go and book the tennis court.
他们就是在做这个，不是吗？他们基本上是在装扮成罗马人。消息传得很快。他们在网球场宣誓的消息传开了。第二天早上，巴黎就有印好的誓词在售卖。路易的兄弟们和宫廷里的其他强硬派对此感到极其愤怒。我喜欢他们解决整个问题的方案。拉特鲁瓦伯爵说，太棒了，我去把那个网球场订下来。
He does. He books the tennis court to stop them. It's really funny. The question that's on my mind that I haven't been able to resolve is, did he play tennis? Well, who knows? I mean, once you've booked the court, you're mad not to use it, right? What else are you going to be doing? Especially if it's raining.
他确实这么做了。他订下网球场是为了阻止他们。这真的很有趣。我脑子里一直有个没能解决的问题：他打网球吗？谁知道呢？毕竟，一旦你订了球场，不打就太傻了，对吧？不然你还能干什么？尤其是在下雨的时候。
Anyway, the 23rd of June, so three days later, is going to be this big séance royale, a big meeting, summit meeting where Louis is going to decide all this? And again, crazily, I mean, such a failure of statecraft, I suppose. He humiliates the third estate. The church and the nobility are seated first. The third estate have to wait outside in the rain for an hour, and then they're brought in through a side door. When they get in, they find that necker
总之，6月23日，也就是三天后，将举行盛大的皇家会议，一个大型会议，路易将在会上决定这一切？同样疯狂的是，我想这真是治国方略的失败。他羞辱了第三等级。教会和贵族先入座。第三等级不得不在雨中等了一个小时，然后被从侧门带进去。当他们进去时，发现内克尔
is not there it is clear that necker has lost the argument within the regime and he is refusing to come or has been told to stay away and louis speaks for just half an hour he says i'll give you some of what you want taxes will now have to be approved by the nation's representatives and i promise that the estates general will meet regularly but he says this stuff about the national assembly is gibberish and nonsense i will not accept it the distinction of the three orders of the state is not up for debate the clergy and their nobility must run their own affairs and they can't be run for them by the third estate because of course if the moderate position is to emulate the British constitution, Britain does have that division, House of Lords and House of Commons.
不在那里。很明显，内克尔在政权内部的争论中输了，他拒绝出席或者被告知不要露面。路易只讲了半个小时，他说我会给你们想要的一部分，税收现在必须由国家代表批准，我承诺三级会议将定期召开，但他又说关于国民议会的这些东西是胡言乱语，我不会接受。三个等级的区别不容辩论，教士和贵族必须管理他们自己的事务，不能由第三等级代劳，因为当然，如果温和派的立场是效仿英国宪法，英国确实有那种划分，上议院和下议院。
Yeah. I mean, it's not a holy reactionary in that sense. Yeah, it's not a holy reactionary. I mean, they're going well beyond the British constitution now, aren't they? And they're going well beyond the American constitution. So they are doing away with the checks and balances that were so important for the United States because they're all about the general will, aren't they? Which is not something that the founding fathers in America were so keen on. Now, had Louis said all this two years earlier, maybe the whole story would be different, but he didn't. And it's too late because as we said, they've self-radicalized.
是的。我的意思是，在这个意义上，他并不是完全的反动派。是的，他不是完全的反动派。我的意思是，他们现在已经远远超出了英国宪法，不是吗？他们也远远超出了美国宪法。所以他们废除了对美国来说非常重要的制衡机制，因为他们追求的是公意，不是吗？这并不是美国开国元勋们所热衷的东西。现在，如果路易两年前就说了这一切，也许整个故事会不同，但他没有。而且太晚了，因为正如我们所说，他们已经自我激进化了。
So when he gets up and goes out after half an hour, everybody else starts to file out and the workmen come back in to demolish the platform. And the third estate do not move. They're sitting there. They will not move. This is their hall and they're not going to budge. And the Marquis de Trebreze. He's the suit guy. The suits man. The correct thing you wear. Derek Guy. Yeah, he's him. He says to them, you've got to go. Right, we're trying to clear the room. You've got to go.
所以当他半小时后起身离开时，其他人也开始陆续离开，工人们回来拆除平台。而第三等级没有动。他们坐在那里。他们不会动。这是他们的厅，他们不会让步。特雷泽侯爵。就是那个穿西装的人。西装男。穿戴得体的那位。德里克·盖伊。是的，就是他。他对他们说，你们得走。好了，我们要清场了。你们得走。
And Mirabeau, by his own account, which is maybe a little bit self-dramatizing, says, go and tell those who have sent you that we are here by the will of the people and we will only be driven out at the points of bayonets. Very impressive stuff. And the Marquess, he retreats because he's such a stickler for protocol. He retreats walking slowly backwards.
而米拉波，据他自己的说法，可能有点自我戏剧化，他说，去告诉派你来的人，我们是凭人民的意志来到这里的，除非用刺刀逼迫，否则我们绝不会离开。非常令人印象深刻。那位侯爵退缩了，因为他是个极其讲究礼节的人。他慢慢地向后退着离开了。
It's a very strange image. This man with a face like a crater has given this speech to him. Well, but etiquette is etiquette, isn't it? It is. And then Louis Paul. Louis is just not a hard man. He's not ruthless. Because when Marcus tells Louis this, Louis just says, oh, well, let them stay.
这是一个非常奇怪的画面。这个长着一张坑坑洼洼脸的男人对他发表了这番演讲。嗯，但礼节就是礼节，不是吗？确实。然后路易保罗。路易根本不是个强硬的人。他不冷酷。因为当侯爵告诉路易这件事时，路易只是说，哦，好吧，让他们待着吧。
If they want to stay, let them stay. Fair dues. So it's a classic Louis. He sort of parades his authority, but then he never, ever enforces it. He always gives in. So the next few days, more and more people join this National Assembly from the clergy and the nobility. And then on the 27th of June, only four days later,
如果他们想待着，就让他们待着吧。公平合理。所以这是典型的路易。他展示了自己的权威，但从不真正执行。他总是妥协。所以在接下来的几天里，越来越多来自教士和贵族的人加入了这个国民议会。然后在6月27日，仅仅四天后，
Louis does give in. His position has eroded. It's a classic example of how in revolutionary situations, momentum is all. His position has eroded. And he says, okay, yeah, I've changed my mind. I give up. He orders the nobility and the clergy join the national
路易确实妥协了。他的立场已经动摇。这是革命形势下势头就是一切的典型例子。他的立场动摇了。他说，好吧，是的，我改变主意了。我放弃。他下令贵族和教士加入国民
assembly now you know after all this i've lost there is an explosion of joy in versailles in a very very revealing scene so people are chanting the crowds are in versailles and they're shouting vive necker vive revoir and on the balcony of louis the 14th bedroom which overlooks the marble court of versailles louis and marion trinac come out onto the balcony and they pretend to look happy and to wave to the crowds who are shouting long live the king and actually it's i always think it's a telling detail people are very shocked at the appearance of marion trinac obviously she's a grieving mother yeah she's grief-stricken and they say lots of people said she looks as though she's aged so much her hair
议会。现在你知道，经历了这一切，我输了。凡尔赛爆发了欢乐的浪潮，在一个非常非常能说明问题的场景中，人们在欢呼，凡尔赛的人群在喊着“内克尔万岁，勒瓦尔万岁”。在俯瞰凡尔赛大理石庭院的路易十四卧室阳台上，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特走到阳台上，假装很高兴，向高呼国王万岁的人群挥手。实际上，我一直认为这是一个很有说明性的细节，人们对玛丽·安托瓦内特的出现感到非常震惊，显然她是一位悲伤的母亲，是的，她悲痛欲绝，很多人说她看起来老了很多，她的头发
is gray she's not wearing jewels she looks as though she's aged so much. Her hair is gray. She's not wearing jewels. She looks terrible. You know, it's understandable. And she seems to be forcing back tears. And she brings out her children, Marie-Thérèse and Louis. Marie-Thérèse is 10 and Louis is 4. And she brings them out, which is the royal family have never done anything like this before. And the crowd go mad.
花白了，她没有戴珠宝，她看起来糟透了。你知道，这是可以理解的。她似乎在强忍泪水。她带出了她的孩子们，玛丽-泰蕾莎和路易。玛丽-泰蕾莎10岁，路易4岁。她带他们出来，这是王室以前从未做过的事。人群疯狂了。
They're cheering and all this kind of stuff but i always think there's a sense even here that they have become prisoners of the crowd that they're prisoners of the situation they're parading yeah they've lost agency to appease the crowd yeah exactly now some people think in fact lots of people think this is probably the end of the story now the french revolution has come and gone so arthur young the traveler that i mentioned famously wrote in his journal or whatever it was the whole business now seems over and the revolution complete but not everybody so that guy that we mentioned the marquis de ferriere the nobleman the enlightenment guy he writes to his sister the next day and he says we've come close to the bloodiest catastrophe the weakness of the
他们欢呼雀跃，诸如此类，但我总觉得即使在这里，他们也已经成为了人群的囚徒，他们是局势的囚徒，他们在游行，是的，他们为了安抚人群而失去了主动权，是的，正是如此。现在有些人认为，实际上很多人认为这可能就是故事的结局了，法国大革命已经结束了。所以我提到的那位旅行者阿瑟·杨在日记里写道，整个事情现在似乎结束了，革命已经完成。但并非所有人都是这么想的，所以我们提到的那位费里埃侯爵，那位贵族，启蒙运动者，第二天写信给他的妹妹，他说我们已经接近了最血腥的灾难，政府的软弱
government seems to allow for anything people speak openly in the palais royal of massacring us our houses are marked out for murder he goes on to say he says everything may seem tranquil but the troops are no longer obeying their officers he says the estates general 1789 may be celebrated one day he says but it will be by a banner of blood that will be carried to all the parts of europe so would it be fair to say dominic that storm clouds really are gathering though they are gathering because in the next few days there are rumors that there are military units on the march out there in the provinces people are swapping stories and they're saying they've heard that
似乎让一切皆有可能。人们在王宫公开谈论屠杀我们，我们的房子被标记为谋杀目标。他继续说，他说一切看起来可能很平静，但军队不再服从他们的军官了。他说1789年的三级会议有一天可能会被纪念，他说，但那将是一面血旗，会被带到欧洲的各个角落。那么，多米尼克，说乌云密布是否公平？它们确实在聚集，因为在接下来的几天里，有传言说省里的军事单位正在行军，人们在交换故事，他们说他们听说
there are tens of thousands of troops coming towards the capital from the frontier garrisons and in particular german and swiss troops who fight for the french king mirabeau says does the king doubt the loyalty of his people and lou Louis has to issue a public statement saying, these troops are to reinforce the troops already in Paris, which are proving unreliable, which is true. Well, the French Guard in particular in Paris, there have been stories about them disobeying their officers, fraternizing with looters, all of this kind of thing.
有成千上万的军队正从边境驻军向首都进发，特别是为法国国王效力的德国和瑞士军队。米拉波说，国王怀疑他人民的忠诚吗？路易不得不发表公开声明说，这些军队是为了加强巴黎现有的军队，因为巴黎的军队表现不可靠，这是事实。嗯，特别是巴黎的法国卫队，有关于他们不服从军官、与掠夺者勾结等等的故事。
And there is a sense as more and more of these stories mount that the crowds in Paris are getting ever more radical, the rhetoric ever more violent. Early July, there's a story that the crowd sees a suspected police informant and they beat him to death. There is this kind of latent simmering violence. And in Versailles, some of Louis' advisors say, sure, you gave in to the National Assembly the other day, but this is the last chance now. We have to act. This is the last opportunity we'll ever have to seize control of the situation. Sack Necker, put an end to all of this nonsense. Use these new troops from the frontiers to secure the city. The question is whether the army will obey orders. The royal commander, the Duke de Broglie, says it is risky. He says, we don't have enough troops to secure all of Paris, to fight our way through all of Paris. Other advisors say, so tellingly, get out of Versailles now. You don't want to be a prisoner. Let's go to Metz
随着这些故事越来越多，人们感觉到巴黎的人群变得越来越激进，言辞越来越暴力。7月初，有消息称人群看到一名疑似警察线人，并将他殴打致死。有一种潜在的、酝酿中的暴力。在凡尔赛，路易的一些顾问说，当然，你前几天向国民议会妥协了，但这是最后的机会了。我们必须采取行动。这是我们夺回局势控制权的最后机会。解雇内克尔，结束所有这些胡闹。利用这些来自边境的新军队来保卫城市。问题是军队是否会服从命令。皇家指挥官布罗伊公爵说这很冒险。他说，我们没有足够的军队来保卫整个巴黎，无法在整个巴黎杀出一条血路。其他顾问说，说得很有道理，现在就离开凡尔赛。你不想成为囚徒。我们去梅斯
on the frontier out in Alsace. We're so close to foreign support. We can get foreign aid if necessary. Paris is gone. But then other people say, no, we can't do that because if we abandon Paris now, we'll never get it back. We'll be setting ourselves against the capital and we can't do that. Right. And a king leaving his own capital to go inside with foreign powers is not a good look. And that is true now and it will be true in due course, as we will see. Of course it is, Tom. It's so ominous, all of these conversations, because they're anticipating so much of what will follow. But anyway, Louis finally makes up his mind and he says, okay, I know what we'll do. We'll go with your first idea. So on the night of the 11th of July,
在阿尔萨斯的边境。我们离外国的支持很近。如果有必要，我们可以得到外国援助。巴黎已经完了。但其他人说，不，我们不能那样做，因为如果我们现在放弃巴黎，我们就永远拿不回来了。我们将与首都对立，我们不能那样做。没错。而且一个国王离开自己的首都去投靠外国势力，这看起来可不好。这在现在是事实，在适当的时候也会是事实，正如我们将看到的。当然是这样，汤姆。所有这些对话都太不祥了，因为它们预示了随后发生的太多事情。但无论如何，路易最终下定了决心，他说，好吧，我知道我们该怎么做了。我们就按你的第一个主意办。所以，在7月11日晚上，
the plan is set in motion. Late that night, out of nowhere, Necker is dismissed. Louis tells him, you're sacked. You are exiled from France. You have to leave the kingdom immediately and you cannot go through Paris. You cannot visit the capital. You can't stop on the way. You must go to Switzerland. A noble deputy called Gaston de Lévis, who knows all about this business, he sends a warning to his wife who's in the capital that night and the warning reads as follows don't go out at all tomorrow there will surely be a dreadful commotion and one cannot know how things will go well dominic what a cliffhanger the clock is ticking down towards one of the most famous dates in the whole, not just of French history, but of history, full stop the 14th of July, 1789, the day the Bastille falls.
计划开始实施。那天深夜，内克尔毫无征兆地被解职。路易告诉他，你被解雇了。你被驱逐出法国。你必须立即离开王国，而且你不能经过巴黎。你不能访问首都。你中途不能停留。你必须去瑞士。一位名叫加斯顿·德·莱维斯的贵族代表，他非常了解这件事，那天晚上给在首都的妻子发出了警告，警告内容如下：明天千万不要出门，肯定会发生可怕的骚乱，没人知道事情会变成什么样。好吧，多米尼克，真是个悬念。时钟正在倒计时，走向整个法国历史上，不，是整个历史上最著名的日期之一，1789年7月14日，巴士底狱陷落的日子。
And we will be looking at that in our next episode. And if you can't wait, you know the drill. You can hear it right now by joining the Restless History Club at therestlesshistory.com. But if you don't do that, it'll be coming very soon anyway. So we will see you soon. A bientot. Au revoir. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们将在下一集讨论这个问题。如果你等不及了，你知道该怎么做。你可以通过加入therestlesshistory.com的Restless History Club立即收听。但如果你不这样做，它很快也会发布。所以我们很快会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。